Keck-Weight.
Ich habe übelst Muskelkater
in den Beinen.
Ich habe mir noch so eine Fitnessuhr gekauft.
Ich habe mir gedacht,
ja, lass doch mal kurz tracken,
wie schnell ich
so drei Kilometer rennen kann.
Das war keine so gute Idee.
Am Ende waren es 3,3
und ich dachte danach eigentlich,
ja gut, das ging doch halbwegs.
Jetzt habe ich übelst Muskelkater
in den Beinen.
Ich bin das nicht gewohnt.
Aber ich habe ja die Hoffnung,
dass,
wenn ich das öfters mache,
ja, das kommt auch noch dabei.
Das ist richtig.
Aber ich habe die Hoffnung,
falls ich das öfters machen soll,
dass es dann nicht mehr so schlimm wird.
Moin.
Warum warst du davor
mit dem falschen Counter?
Hast du gebannt
auf Twitch?
Ja, aber das stimmt wohl.
Wobei ich glaube,
Muskelkater liegt weniger am Alter,
mehr am nicht in Übung sein.
Also ich bin auch nicht
so ordentlich schnell gewesen.
Also ich kann euch das,
Moment, ich kann euch das glaube ich sogar sagen,
wie schnell ich gewesen bin.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die App
die App aufmachen.
So, Kalender.
Ich kann euch das sagen, wartet mal.
Ich glaube, das war am Freitag.
Hier.
Ja, also.
Steht das da irgendwo?
Erster Kilometer
habe ich gebraucht
8 Minuten 24.
Zweiter Kilometer
habe ich gebraucht
8 Minuten 29.
Das ist so,
naja.
Ähm.
Ja, nächster Kilometer habe ich gebraucht
9 Minuten 6.
Ja.
Komplett, komplett.
Ja, ich wollte mal gucken,
ob ich so 3 Kilometer,
ich hab, am Ende waren es 3,3
war die Strecke lang.
Wie lange ich das,
wie lange ich das durchhalte.
Letzten 300 Meter
bin ich ein bisschen schneller gerannt.
Vielleicht war ich deswegen
dann auch so im Arsch.
Ja.
Also ich habe im Internet mal geguckt,
das ist so ein typischer,
so ein typischer Einsteiger-Speed.
8 Minuten 30.
pro Kilometer.
Aber ob ich das nach dem Muskelkater öfters
mache, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich, ich, ich, ich
bin das am Freitag, bin ich das geflitzt.
3,3 Kilometer.
Ey, in Wirklichkeit waren es 4.
In Wirklichkeit waren es ein bisschen mehr.
Ich bin am Anfang ein bisschen normal gelaufen,
dann bin ich 3,3, wenn ich die restliche Strecke
gejoggt.
Und heute ist Sonntagmorgen
und ich habe immer noch übelst Muskelkater
in den Beinen.
Weiß nicht, wie lange sowas geht.
Naja.
Habe ich schon für den Sub
Nesti
Unesti
Unesti Company?
Das wird besser, je öfters man das...
Ja, das ist klar.
Das ist ja bei so ziemlich allen Sachen.
Aber ich muss sagen, es ist tatsächlich
witzigerweise nur in den Beinen,
nicht irgendwie großartig Rücken oder Arme.
Ja, also ich das letzte Mal,
zum ersten Mal,
habe ich langer Zeit ein bisschen gerannt,
weil ich übelst Muskelkater in den Ärmen hatte.
Aber jetzt ist es nur in den Beinen.
Ja, also...
Und ich war dazu auch nur motiviert.
Also,
so weit komme ich nicht im Leben.
Das Einzige, was mich dazu tatsächlich
ein bisschen motiviert hat, ist,
dass ich mir so eine Fitnessuhr gekauft habe.
Und die habe ich eigentlich gar nicht gekauft
zum Tracken vom Rennen oder so.
Also eigentlich, wenn ich meine
normalen Daily-Runden mache,
wollte ich halt einfach mal gucken
und aufzeichnen, so wie viele Kilometer
das alles so sind.
Da dachte ich mir so, gut, guck doch mal,
ob du diese kleine Runde da durchhältst.
Also, ich war schon ziemlich im Arsch.
Ich war schon ziemlich...
Ich meine, es ging, aber ich war schon
ziemlich kaputt.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe übelst Muskelkater
in den Beinen.
So, dann lasst uns doch jetzt
gleich mal gucken.
Nicht Geizhals, was will ich denn sagen?
GitHub, Shithub, Shithub Weekly.
Was gibt's denn?
Außer AI. AI! Jawohl, wer hätte das gedacht?
Ha!
AI.
React-UI braucht keiner.
Full-Stack-GUI-Library.
Für Rust. Ich will in Rust sicherlich
kein UI-Zeug programmieren. Rust ist schon eh
anstrengend genug zu programmieren.
Und dann auch UI. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ja, sieht auf den ersten Blick
nicht so schlimm aus.
Aber man sieht,
man sieht schon ganz viel...
Moment.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie JavaScript-Zeug.
Das ist jetzt nicht TSX,
nee, JSX, sondern es ist RSX.
Das ist, dass es dafür
schon irgendwelche Makros braucht.
Weißt du schon?
Irgendwas ist da im Argen,
was Rust und Rust-Libraries angeht.
Und das ist jetzt auch ein schönes
Example. Lass uns mal die anderen Examples
angucken.
Die sind bestimmt nicht...
Ja.
Da kommen wir schon hin.
Das Rust hat nicht so...
Ja. Moment.
Es ist Fake-HTML,
obwohl es kein HTML...
Moment. Kopieren Emojis?
Das ist neu, oder?
Seit wann...
Seit wann gibt es hier ein Emoji-Menü,
wenn man rechts klickt?
Und die große Preisfrage ist...
Warum?
Warum gibt es hier ein Emoji-Menü?
Seit wann...
Moment, Moment.
Seit wann gibt es ein Emoji?
Seit 2018?
Echt so?
Das ist mir noch...
Das...
Das ist mir...
Moment.
Ist das vielleicht auf normalen Webseiten, nicht?
Ah!
Ach so!
Ah ja.
Was...
Ok, Google...
Was empfiehlt Google heute, sich anzugucken?
Eher weniger.
Ja.
Ach, das ist, weil das hier ein...
Code-Feld ist.
Deswegen zeigt es das an.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Das...
Ok.
Also, hübsch ist es wirklich nicht anzusehen.
Muss ich echt sagen.
Also, ich verstehe, dass Rust relativ viele Fans hat und auch viele Fan-Boys hat.
Aber schön zu lesen ist Rust oftmals nicht.
Also, ich habe schon Rust-Source-Code gesehen.
Da ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger die komplette, so 120 Zeilen, quasi Code-Zeile voll mit irgendwelchen Dingern, die sehr unleserlich sind.
Das ist auch so typisches Rust-Zeug.
Unwrap.
Und...
Ja, das...
Rust ist, glaube ich...
Ich glaube, Rust hat noch mehr Sonderzeichen in der Syntax als C++.
Was es nicht unbedingt schlechter macht, weil es eigentlich so gut wie nicht schlechter sein könnte als C++.
Aber Sonderzeichen ist schon...
Ich glaube, Komplexität von der Rust-Syntax ist wirklich enorm.
Ja.
Ja, das ist auch so ein typisches Rust-Ding.
So.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch hier?
Ich musste gerade auf dem Vorschau-Monitor was gucken.
Okay.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ja, außer, dass ich Muskelkater als Fuck habe, ist alles gut.
Keckel.
Keine Ahnung.
AI.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Wim!
Wim trendet?
Warum trendet Wim?
Der Wim-Erfinder ist gestorben letztens.
Woher der Muskelkater?
Weil ich...
Ich habe mir noch eine Fitness-Uhr gekauft und ich wollte mal gucken, wie schnell ich so eine 4-Kilometer-Runde rennen kann.
Ich bin eigentlich...
Also die ersten...
Ich bin...
Eigentlich bin ich nur 3,3 Kilometer gerannt.
Vorher ein bisschen, ein bisschen eingelaufen, ja.
Und es war nicht sonderlich schnell, aber es war anscheinend sehr anstrengend.
Weil das war am Freitag.
Es war Freitagnachmittag.
Und ich habe heute immer noch...
Gestern war ganz schlimm.
Ich habe heute immer noch Muskelkater als Fuck in den Beinen.
Aber glücklicherweise nur in den Beinen.
Nicht...
Nicht im Rücken und auch nicht in den Armen.
In den Armen hatte ich letztens übelst...
Nee, nee, nee.
Mit Wanderstelz habe ich keinen Muskelkater mehr.
Das mache ich ja jeden Tag genug, ja.
Aber...
3,3 Kilometer rennen oder joggen war für mich zu anstrengend.
Ich wollte einfach mal gucken, ob ich das hinkriege.
Ich war auch nicht sonderlich schnell.
Ich habe es euch ja gerade vorgelesen.
Also ich habe irgendwie...
Im Durchschnitt irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung...
Drei...
Ähm...
Quatsch...
8 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer gebraucht.
Wenn man im Internet guckt, ist das auch so ziemlich das, was so normal ist für Einsteiger.
So, warum trendet Wim auf einmal?
Wie gesagt, ich dachte der...
Kann es sein...
Dass die jetzt ganz viel merchen?
Was der Erfinder vorher nicht wollte?
Oder wie ist das jetzt?
Weil es tut sich enorm viel, oder?
In Wim.
Ja.
Guck mal, das hier dürfte das letzte...
Das hier dürfte das letzte Comet vom...
Hier ist Zetge.
Das war sein letztes Comet hier.
Das ist der Wim-Erfinder.
Letztes Comet, 9. Juli.
Ja.
Ja, mittlerweile merke ich das.
Ich bin jetzt ja auch fast 40.
Das dauert noch kurz, aber nicht mehr allzu lange.
Jetzt sterben langsam schon die Leute.
Deren Software ich benutze.
Ich meine, Linus ist auch nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Also, die sind alle mittlerweile schon ziemlich, ziemlich alt.
Ich ja auch.
Web-Dev for Beginners.
AI, AI, AI.
Home Assistant trendet.
Zu Recht.
AI, AI, AI.
Bla, blub.
Juckt mich alles nett.
Ja, ja, der auch.
Die sind alle ziemlich alt schon.
Ich meine, die...
So diese First Generation IT-Computer-Pionier-Generation,
die ist ja schon zum größten Teil sehr alt oder schon gestorben.
Ja.
Ja, das hoffe ich auch.
Vor allem braucht er eine Nachfolge,
der da auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen ausflippt.
Ich meine, Linux-Kernel-Entwicklung wäre nicht mehr das Gleiche,
wenn da nicht ab und zu mal einer übelst ausrasten würde.
Wobei man ihm echt...
Wobei man ihm echt zugutehalten muss.
Er hat ja, er hat ja vor ein paar Jahren mal gesagt,
er ist jetzt reformt.
Er ist, er ist irgendwie ein halbes Jahr in sich gegangen
und will jetzt, will jetzt, will jetzt nicht mehr so ausrasten.
Und das hat anscheinend auch funktioniert.
Also ich glaube, seitdem sind seine Ausraste deutlich weniger geworden.
Ja, jetzt wirklich.
Der ist im Vergleich zu, meine ich ja,
der ist im Vergleich zu früher mega entspannt geworden.
Also früher ist er ja alle, ja, keine Ahnung,
gab's ja, gab's ja wöchentlich irgendwelche größeren Rants.
Aber mittlerweile kommt das ja, kommt das wirklich selten vor,
dass der mal, dass der sich mal aufregt.
Das Letzte, was ich mitgekriegt habe, ist,
worauf er sich drüber aufgeregt hat,
dass Intel irgendwelche kaputten, kaputten Netzwerksachen
committen wollte.
Irgendwelche Leute von Intel
hat er sich übelst drüber aufgeregt,
aber irgendwo auch zu Recht.
Und dass der, dass der Intel-Typ
dann so abfällig darauf geantwortet hat,
hat ihn natürlich noch mehr ragen lassen.
Und das ist das Letzte, was ich mitgekriegt habe.
Im Vergleich zu früher rastet der kaum noch aus.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
das weiß ich jetzt aber auch nur vom Hörensagen,
aber kann man im Internet, kann man nachgucken,
dass das in Schweden wohl, äh, nicht in Schweden, in Finnland,
dass das in Finnland wohl, sag mal,
verbreitet, relativ verbreitet ist,
dass die Leute viel fluchen und mit Schimpfwörter um sich werfen.
Das scheint da eher, eher quasi,
das scheint da gar nicht so, da wirst du gar nicht
schepp angeguckt, das ist wohl in Finnland fast normal,
dass du den ganzen Tag am Meckern, beziehungsweise
was er meckert, so am rumfluchen bist.
Scheint, scheint so etwas finnische Kultur zu sein.
Also wir können auch froh sein, dass Linus das so lange macht,
weil, überlegt euch mal, da hätten,
also er hätte da nicht so die, die, die, die finale Sicht drauf.
Wer weiß, wie viel Enterprise-Business-Shit
bei Linus schon, äh, bei, ja, bei Linus abgehen würde,
wenn, wenn er da nicht an der Position wäre.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich hoffe, er macht's noch lange, ja?
Und dann mal die wirklich, die, die wöchentliche Erinnerung.
Kennt, kennt irgendjemand eine gute IT-News-Summary für die Woche?
Bisher habe ich keine gefunden
und auch alles, was mir empfohlen wurde, fand ich nicht gut.
Heise und Golem haben das eingestellt, Weekly-Summaries zu bringen,
oder zumindest, wenn, dann, wenn.
Dann bringen sie die zu spät für Sonntagmorgen.
Ja, also, das heißt Dünnschiss auf Finnisch.
Die Pirate Bay-Typen kommen aus Schweden?
Keine Ahnung, wo die herkommen.
Torrent ist doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt.
Selbstverständlich hat jeder von uns Torrent nur
zum Linux-Distribution runterladen benutzt bisher, stimmt's?
Man würde sich ja nichts, nichts anderes, würde man da machen.
Gegoogelt oder wusstest du das?
Ich habe es gegoogelt, das wusste ich nicht.
Eventuell, eventuell auch noch für selbst angelegte Sicherheitskopien.
Aber sonst nur für Linux und selbst angelegte Sicherheitskopien
würden wir Torrent verwenden.
Jetzt mal, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich habe ewig nichts mehr.
Sei es Linux-Distribution oder eigenhändig angelegte Sicherheitskopien.
Ich habe ewig nichts mehr über Torrent runtergeladen.
Magst du ans Trinken erinnern?
Ich habe ewig nichts mehr mit Torrent runtergeladen.
Hochgeladen auch nicht.
Das ist schon wirklich lange her.
Ich würde sagen, das ist über 10 Jahre her,
dass ich wirklich Torrent mal ernsthaft benutzt habe.
Ich kann mir das mit 10 Jahren immer ganz gut merken,
weil 2013 bin ich hier in das Haus eingezogen,
in das Haus vom Opa.
Und dementsprechend weiß ich, seitdem kann ich mich an keine,
keine Torrent-Usage mehr erinnern.
Und dementsprechend weiß ich gar nicht, was da so aktuell angesagt ist.
Und Chat, was habe ich verpasst die Woche?
Ich war die Woche ja nicht, ich glaube, ich war nur einmal.
Lass mal kurz gucken, wann war ich denn zuletzt on?
Mobile, Alter.
Ja, guck mal, vor 6 Tagen.
Das war quasi am Montag.
Montagabend war ich zuletzt on.
Dreieinhalb Stunden.
Fast eine Woche her.
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen?
Ich sollte nicht auf dem Vorschaubildschirm in irgendwelche Sachen reinkommen.
Ja, ich war lange nicht mehr da.
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst? War die Woche irgendwas Spannendes?
Also, lass mal überlegen.
Habe ich irgendwas mitgekriegt?
War irgendwas so IT-mäßig?
Also diese ganze Microsoft-Token-Geschichte war letzte Woche?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also zumindest nichts, wo ich mich dran erinnern könnte.
Ja, ja stimmt, das war.
Das war tatsächlich, das habe ich mitbekommen.
Das ist eine .NET Library, die jetzt E-Mail-Adressen scannt.
Wobei ich da sagen muss, ganz ehrlich.
Also, ich muss da mal kurz was zu sagen.
Vielleicht haben das manche Leute mitbekommen, wenn nicht, erzähle ich euch das mal.
Es gibt auf GitHub eine Library, die nennt sich Mock.
Das ist eine Library für das .NET Ökosystem.
Was sie macht, ist auch vollkommen egal.
So.
Und da gab es letzte Woche ein bisschen Drama.
Und zwar, der Maintainer von Mock hat, also das ist eine relativ beliebte Library,
die wurde auch ein paar Millionen Mal schon runtergeladen, wenn man sich die Nougat,
guck mal hier, das hat 478 Millionen Downloads, wenn man sich das anguckt.
So.
Und der Maintainer von dieser Library hat noch ein zweites Projekt, das nennt sich SponsorLink.
SponsorLink soll irgendein Webservice werden, wenn ich das soweit richtig verfolgt habe,
um bessere Spendenverteilung für Open Source Projekte irgendwie zu ermöglichen.
Ich habe mir das nur am Rande angeguckt.
Zumindest hat er letzte Woche SponsorLink in Mock eingebaut.
Und das .NET Ökosystem Internet ist halb explodiert.
Weil?
Weil, was passiert ist unter der Haube, das ist ja auch blöd gewesen, ja,
was passiert ist unter der Haube, dadurch, dass er diese SponsorLink-Geschichte eingebaut hat,
wird jetzt bei jedem Compile-Vorgang mit dieser Library dabei,
wird jetzt ein Command-Line-Befehl ausgeführt, um die E-Mail-Adresse aus der Git-Config auszulesen.
Dann wird die E-Mail-Adresse gehashed und an SponsorLink geschickt.
So, damit man quasi überprüfen kann und Dankesnachrichten in der Compile-Message anzeigen lassen kann,
dass man überprüfen kann, wer sponsort das Projekt und wer nicht und sowas.
Okay, also, dazu muss ich echt mal zwei Sachen loswerden.
Das erste ist, es ist eine ziemlich blöde Idee gewesen, das einzubauen.
Vor allem nicht, sagen wir mal so, offensichtlich darauf hinzuweisen, um das ganze Opt-in zu machen.
So.
Oder zumindest etwas breiter zu kommunizieren.
Das war blöd.
Was aber auch blöd war.
Was aber auch blöd ist, ist, wie komplett die Leute wieder eskaliert sind.
Ich find's komplett affig, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Also, ich verstehe, dass die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben, das dadurch zu benutzen.
Dass die Leute sagen, okay, sie können jetzt quasi keine Library gebrauchen, die automatische E-Mail-Adressen auslässt.
Sie trauen dem Library-Autor nicht mehr und sowas.
Das kann ja jeder für sich selbst überlegen und kann sagen, okay, das will ich nicht mehr machen.
Aber.
Also, diese Welle der Empörung, die auch heute noch, wenn man sich mal in die Issues reinguckt, ja.
Die auch, die auch immer noch anhält.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Wann haben GitHub-Issues, wenn's nicht wirklich was richtig Großes bekannt ist.
Wann haben GitHub-Issues 642 Comments?
So.
Und die Leute haben's komplett übertrieben.
Ich mein, man darf an der Stelle ja auch mal, denke ich, nicht vergessen, oder man sollte es an der Stelle mal erwähnen.
Die Library gibt's schon ganz lange.
Der Typ hat nie Geld dafür.
Der Typ hat nie Geld dafür genommen.
Der hat die weiterentwickelt, maintained seit vielen Jahren.
Komplett ehrenamtlich.
Kostenlos.
Viele Unternehmen verdienen ihr Geld mit Projekten, die diese Library verwenden.
Und das hat er alles für, ja, just for fun gemacht, so.
Natürlich hat das jetzt verkackt.
Dadurch, dass er so Sachen eingebaut hat, wie, dass E-Mail-Adressen ausgelesen werden.
Aber wie manche Leute da drauf reagieren haben, ja.
Also, das ist wirklich unter aller Sau.
Also, ich kann's, ich kann's verstehen, wenn nach solchen Beispielen keiner Bock hat, irgendwas mehr Open Source zur Verfügung zu stellen,
beziehungsweise das weiter, weiter zu maintainen.
Dann machen's die Leute wie ich, ja.
Die releasen irgendwas und kümmern sich dann nie wieder drum.
Ich weiß, wie viele Issues hab ich mittlerweile.
Okay.
Das ist ja auch nur ein kleines Projekt.
18.
Ja.
Selbstverständlich liegt das nicht an Fehlern von mir, sondern an...
Nur, dass die Leute nicht wissen, wie man's verwenden kann.
Die Leute nicht wissen, wie man's verwendet.
Zumindest...
Zumindest haben das...
Wisst ihr?
Also, ich finde...
Ich finde, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt...
Also, es gibt zwei unterschiedliche Ansichten dazu.
So.
Also...
Die, die ich nachvollziehen kann, ja.
Das erste ist, dass die Leute sich beschweren und sich persönlich quasi, ähm...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Was ist da das richtige Wort für...
Ja, bisschen angegriffen fühlen oder auch genervt fühlen, dass eine Library, die sie verwendet haben, die sie gern verwendet haben, die ihnen auch viel...
Ja.
Die sie gern verwendet haben, die ihnen auch viel Value bringt.
Letztendlich vielleicht für sie nicht mehr verwendbar ist.
Und auch die Art und Weise nicht gut finden.
Das verstehe ich.
Aber...
Ich meine, man muss mal in diesen...
In diesen Thread hier reingucken.
Wie da manche Leute drüber schreiben, so als ist der Typ jetzt ihnen in irgendeiner Art und Weise verpflichtet.
Oder sie verlangen jetzt, dass das und das passiert wird.
Und wie die da über den Autor reden, der ehrenamtlich diese Library maintained hat, sei...
Komplett...
Kostenlos und komplett ohne irgendwelche...
Irgendwelche...
Ja...
Aufriss drum zu machen.
Die letzten...
Keine Ahnung...
Acht...
Acht Jahre oder wie alt...
Wie alt das ist.
Also...
Die Leute denken glaube ich, dass das rein durch das...
Benutzen dieser Library...
Sie jetzt in irgendeiner Position wären...
Als hätten sie...
Als hätten sie das...
Keine Ahnung...
Als wären sie irgendwie an der Gründung des Projekts beteiligt gewesen oder so.
Also als wären sie irgendwie Core-Maintainer oder sowas.
Nur weil sie das benutzen.
Also...
Die Leute sind mir da viel zu...
Viel zu...
Wie soll ich sagen...
Viel zu moralisch so wieder drauf.
So nach dem Motto...
Ah...
Ich sehe das so und so und deswegen muss das jetzt so gemacht werden.
Ja...
Genau.
Das denke ich mir auch.
Das Ding ist Open Source.
Wenn sie es wirklich machen wollen und wenn es ihnen so sehr auf den Sack geht...
Können sie sich das Ganze forken und selbst maintainen.
Was ja auch einer probiert hat.
Wo ich meine Zweifel habe, ob das so...
So Traction aufnehmen wird.
Er hätte natürlich auch ein bisschen gesagt...
Ja...
Er hätte natürlich auch ein bisschen schneller zurück rüdern können.
Mittlerweile ist das Ganze ja raus.
Mittlerweile wurde das Ganze ja entfernt.
Allerdings hat er einen Fehler gemacht.
Und zwar...
Er hat das Ganze entfernt.
Er hat SponsorLink...
Er hat SponsorLink entfernt.
Weil es angeblich MacOS Builds kaputt macht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass er es entfernt hat wegen Public...
Ja...
Geflame.
Und dass er vielleicht sogar eingesehen hat...
Dass es keine gute Idee war.
Aber...
Hey...
Man kennt die Leute doch.
Niemand sagt...
Niemand sagt gerne...
Okay, habe ich Scheiße gebaut.
War eine blöde Idee.
Ich entferne das.
Der hatte halt so den Kompromiss gewählt.
Der hat gesagt...
Ja, ich entferne es.
Aber...
Weil es MacOS breakt.
Natürlich hat es die Leute dann auch wieder aufgeregt.
Weil die gesagt haben...
Okay...
Das heißt, in Zukunft kommt das wohl wieder rein.
Es haben sich wahnsinnig viele aufgeregt.
Aber...
Also...
Eine Sache, die mich wirklich, wirklich nervt...
Ist, wenn man sich auch die Comments durchliest.
Also...
Für wie selbstverständlich die Leute es halten...
Dass jemand in seiner Freizeit kostenlos...
Eine Library mit 400 irgendwas Millionen Downloads maintained...
Und...
Durch das pure Benutzen der Library...
Die Leute irgendein Recht daraus ableiten...
Ihm vorschreiben zu können, was er machen soll.
Ja...
Also...
Das finde ich komplett übertrieben.
Und es ist komplett lächerlich, was da wieder gelaufen ist.
Also ich kann...
Wie gesagt...
Ich kann bis zum gewissen Zeit...
Bis zum gewissen Grad beide Seiten verstehen.
Und ich kann auch verstehen...
Wie gesagt...
Man möchte die Library nicht mehr verwenden.
Aber dieses...
Dieses...
Ich...
Ich weiß es besser.
Und dadurch, dass ich die Library benutze...
Bin ich jetzt irgendwie...
Die Leute...
Es ist ja sogar...
Es ist ja sogar noch schlimmer.
Nicht, dass die Leute irgendwie anerkennen...
Okay, der Typ hat sich jetzt jahrelang kostenlos um diese Library gekümmert.
Worauf viele große Projekte auch zugreifen.
Nein, die Leute sind auch noch der Meinung...
Dass...
Weil sie die Library benutzen...
Sie jetzt quasi...
Das große Opfer einer Verschwörung sind.
So.
Wenn ihr das so durchliest hier in den Kommentaren.
So nach dem Motto...
Oh nein!
Wir verwenden diese Library.
Der...
Der Autor ist ganz...
Ist ganz furchtbar böse.
Weil...
Dadurch, dass sowas eingebaut ist...
Bin ich...
Wurde ich Opfer eines...
Äh...
DSGVO-Verstoßes und sowas.
Ganz...
Ganz viel...
Sowas steht da.
Muss man...
Guck her!
Hier!
Und...
Ähm...
Nicht, dass ich noch ankomme mit...
Man muss den Library-Autor verklagen und sowas...
Die sind komplett Lost im Kopf.
Ähm...
Also viele schreiben ja hier auch sehr sinnvolle Sachen.
Aber umso weiter.
Umso weiter...
Diese Diskussion geht hier.
Umso...
Abge...
Umso mehr drehen die Leute ab.
Ja?
Und sagen...
Sind...
Sind da...
Sie müssen...
Können ihm vorschreiben, was er machen soll.
Naja...
Zumindest irgendjemand hat das auch geforkt.
Ah, Fakt, da muss ich mich einloggen.
Irgendjemand, kann man das auch nicht so nachgucken irgendwie?
Doch, lul.
Achso, das ist, wenn man auf Fork klickt, will man, versucht ja das selbst zu forgen.
Guck, es haben ganz viele Leute geforkt, aber die Frage ist halt,
ist halt die Frage, ob das irgendwie Geschwindigkeit bei der Entwicklung aufnehmen wird.
Ich persönlich denke ja nicht.
Also ich gehe davon aus, das Ganze wird im Sande verlaufen.
Und zwar, der Autor wird es wahrscheinlich jetzt mit dieser Art und Weise gut sein lassen,
was er versucht hat.
Ich glaube, ihm ist eingeleuchtet, dass es eine blöde Idee war.
Und der Fork wird nicht weiter verfolgt werden.
Weil ganz im Ernst, die Leute haben gar keinen Bock, das zu maintainen.
Und wenn sie es versuchen, merken sie, wie nervig das durchaus sein kann.
Und wissen es dann vielleicht auch mal zu schätzen, dass sich einer hier seit 8 Jahren,
oder wie lange es das gibt, oder noch,
länger um eine Open-Source-Library kümmert.
Ich meine, wir können mal gucken, wann das erste Comet war.
Das ist was, was mich auch bei GitHub nervt.
Warum gibt es hier unten keine Seiten?
Warum gibt es nur, ich meine, klar, ich könnte mir das Repo jetzt klonen oder so.
Das mache ich jetzt auch.
Keckel.
Ist halt dumm, dass man das machen muss.
Ich hole mir jetzt das Repo.
Und gucke, wann das erste Comet war.
Gibt es eigentlich einen Dependency Injection Service für Mock?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Du weißt das, Tests.
Tests sind bei mir eh überbewertet.
Dementsprechend weiß ich auch nicht, wie man Mock gescheit verwendet.
Ah, zieh da eigentlich schon für den Sub.
So, hoffentlich ist meine 4M gestartet.
Okay, dann lass uns das mal kurz klonen.
Ich will mal schnell schauen, wann das erste...
Erste Comet 2007, Leute.
Alter, 8 Jahre?
Bitte, was?
Ich habe gesagt, seit 8 Jahren Maintain.
Der hat diese Library 15 Jahre.
15 Jahre.
So muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen.
Also 15 Jahre lang gibt es die Library Open Source.
Und er maintaint das, updatet das und stellt es den Leuten zur Verfügung.
Es ist eines der beliebtesten und größten Nougat Libraries schlechthin, würde ich mal sagen.
Mit 478 Spielen.
Also, ja, ich verstehe, dass die Leute angepisst sind.
Aber jetzt so zu tun, als ist das der komplette...
Als würde das alles...
Quasi, ja, so wertlos machen, dass einer seit 15 Jahren da seine Freizeit für investiert.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also die Leute sind irgendwie teilweise nicht ganz dicht im Kopf.
Ne, aktuell regen sich die Leute auf.
Was ist Mock?
Okay, ich versuche das mal kurz zu erklären.
Also, das ist...
Im Prinzip muss man es für den ganzen Skandal...
Was Skandal, ja?
Muss man das für das ganze Drama nicht wissen, was Mock ist.
Mock ist eine Library für .NET.
Library aus dem .NET Ökosystem.
Das viele Leute verwenden.
Das verwenden viele Leute zum Testen ihrer Software.
Nicht wirklich zum Testen, sondern im Teil ihres Testprozesses.
Ich glaube, die haben hier auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel für...
Ja, genau, hier.
Du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn du...
Wie beschreibe ich das?
Wenn du irgendwas testen willst, kann es ja durchaus sein,
dass du Instanzen von Klassen brauchst,
die rein im Test eigentlich gar nicht sinnvoll zu instanzieren sind.
Zum Beispiel, du hast irgendeinen API-Client,
der sich einloggen muss gegenüber einem Live-Service und alles Mögliche.
So, das kannst du jetzt bei einem reinen Test schon ja schlecht machen.
Ja, du bist in irgendeiner Testumgebung,
du bist vielleicht auch nur bei dir auf dem Recher.
Du kannst dich nicht irgendwo bei irgendeinem Live-Service einloggen,
den es gar nicht gibt.
Also musst du das irgendwie mocken.
Also sprich, du erstellst das Objekt mit...
Was von außen so aussieht, wie ein gültiges API-Objekt zum Beispiel,
aber ist es gar nicht.
Es ist nur gemockt.
Und dafür kann man halt diese Library verwenden.
Zum Beispiel, der legt hier eine Instanz von einer Klasse an,
die dieses Interface implementiert.
Und dann kannst du das danach verwenden,
so als hättest du quasi eine gültige Instanz von der Klasse,
auch wenn es vielleicht im Testkontext gar kein Sinn...
Sinn macht, dass man die überhaupt anlegen kann.
Aber nachdem ich es eh nicht teste, weiß ich das auch nicht aus erster Hand.
Ja, genau.
Nächste Woche kann durchaus sein, dass er die Entwicklung einstellt.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht...
gar nicht mal so weit her geholt.
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese Rust...
an diese Rust HTTP...
an diese Rust Web Server Web Framework Library,
wo die Leute dem Entwickler...
Lerax, danke schön für den Sub.
Oh, Bezos muss ins Weltall, Leute.
Wo die Leute dem Entwickler so sehr auf den Sack gegangen sind,
dass er teilweise unsafe Code-Stellen hat,
dass er irgendwann gesagt hat, er hat keinen Bock mehr,
die Library zu maintainen, weil die Leute ihm auf den Sack gehen.
Ich bin mir nicht...
Oh, danke schön, hier, Lerax.
Fünf Subscription.
Pogu.
Extrem.
Nice.
Wir hatten hier Glück gehabt.
Der Schreiger95, der ist auch schon lange am Start.
Spudi-Mann.
Hier.
Du hast richtig Glück gehabt.
Dich habe ich hier noch gar nicht oft gesehen im Chat.
Gleich Sub abgekriegt.
Und der Nico, der ist auch öfters am Start.
Wobei, doch, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe auf dich draufgeklickt, du warst ja schon öfters am Start.
Hatte ich jetzt aber eh gut.
Ich meine, ich kann mich auch nicht alle merken.
Du bist dabei, deinen Rekord zu brechen.
Weiter.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Wir hatten sogar schon Subtrain...
Subtrain...
Level 5 und sowas.
Twitch erzählt auch einen Blödsinn, hä?
Slimbeats, danke schön für den Sub.
Ach, stimmt, gut.
Ich war ja fast seit einer Woche nicht da.
Es ist ja mehr oder weniger Monatsanfang für mich.
Nee.
Das ist nicht Bezos.
Das ist der Zuck.
Will doch.
Ja, ich habe sogar gelesen, dass zur Zeit in der Überlegung ist,
ob Elon Musk und der Zuckerberg,
ob die nicht im Kolosseum sich aufs Maul hauen können.
Anscheinend muss der italienische, frag mich nicht,
römische Kulturminister oder so,
angefragt haben, so nach dem Motto,
wollt ihr das nicht im Kolosseum machen?
Der Lachs am Start, danke schön für den Sub.
Eazle87, der Sputimann hat gegiftet.
Möb am Start.
Poggleu, danke für die ganzen Subs.
Hä, das ist doch schon eine Weile am Laufen,
dass die erst so just for fun geplant haben,
sich aufs Maul zu hauen.
Und dann hatte irgendwann die Oma von irgendeinem, glaube ich,
oder einer von den Leuten, die das gemacht haben,
oder die Mutter von Elon Musk gesagt,
Jungs, beruhigt euch mal.
Und jetzt nimmt das konkrete Formen an.
Ja, aber um das mit der Library mal abzuschließen,
wie gesagt, bin ich mal gespannt, wie sich das Ganze entwickelt.
Ich persönlich denke, das werden die jetzt so gut sein lassen.
Der Typ lässt Sponsoring in der Art und Weise raus
und die Leute lassen den Fork sterben und gut ist,
ich glaube, das wird sich alles wieder beruhigen.
Weil auf Selbstmaintain haben die Leute eh keinen Bock.
Selbstmaintain.
Selbstmaintain suckt.
Waren wir heute Rust?
Schon wieder.
Du meinst Rust Rewrite?
Kein Rust Rewrite.
Ja, macht doch nichts.
Habt ihr auch schon erfahren,
dass die EU-Richtlinie für austauschbare Akkus absolut nichts bringt?
Ne, hab ich nicht erfahren.
Ich hab das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so mitgekriegt.
Was ich dort mitbekommen habe, ist, dass mit USB,
dass Apple natürlich wieder extra Wurst machen will.
Also sie unterstützen USB-C,
aber dann nicht für schnelle Datenübertragung,
nur zum Laden, blablabla.
Das war doch klar, dass da irgendwas wieder drumherum gewurschtelt wird.
Würde ich heute noch WDS verwenden und gibt es bessere Alternativen?
WDS?
Ist das dieses WLAN-Authentifizierungsding?
Oder was ist WDS?
Achso.
Windows Deployment Service.
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Von Windows.
Vielleicht kennt sich da einer im Chat mit aus.
Chatgear ist ja bekanntermaßen extrem,
die Sixthead.
Aber davon hab ich keine Ahnung.
Stufe 3, Leute.
Die Rakete hebt fast ab.
Moin, Leute.
Schön, dass so viele am Start sind jetzt schon.
Ist ja recht früh gewesen.
Ich war, glaub ich, 8.30 Uhr oder so schon am Start.
Okay.
Exzellent.
Dich hab ich schon im Chat gesehen, ja.
Die meisten eigentlich, die öfters da sind,
sagen mir ein bisschen was.
Also, das Erste, das Erste, wo ich dran denke,
der Name sagt mir was, aber nichts Gutes ist natürlich der Chain-Law.
Was soll's?
Wobei, so schlimm ist der gar nicht, ne?
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, warum der überall gebannt ist.
Vielleicht reicht das sich ja auch nur zu sagen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Windows-Containern?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich wusste noch nicht mal,
dass es Windows-Container überhaupt gibt.
Sind das nicht unter...
Ist Docker für Windows nicht eigentlich...
eigentlich auch nur ein Hyper-V-Frontend, oder?
Docker für Windows ist doch auch nur Hyper-V.
Der startet...
Der startet vor Ems
und tut so, als wären's Container.
Bei dicker Desktop, bock.
Ja.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie das unter Windows funktioniert.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht,
warum ich Docker unter Windows verwenden soll,
wenn ich einfach Docker unter Linux verwenden kann
und es da native ist und viel besser funktioniert.
Aber...
Es gibt ja Leute, die sind gezwungen, Windows zu verwenden.
Ich auf der Arbeit übrigens auch.
Ich hab ja einen Windows-Owned-Notebook.
Aber zum Glück...
Zum Glück...
Zum Glück hab ich...
eine Linux-VM, auf der ich root bin
und Internet-Access und sonst alles.
Ich hab mir jetzt einen KVM-Switch gekauft,
hab er noch nicht angeschlossen.
Dass ich zwischen meinem Arbeits-Notebook
und meinem normalen Desktop besser umschalten kann.
Weil es nervt mich teilweise.
KVM-Switch, ja.
Ja, sowas, wo du die Tastatur und die Maus
und theoretisch auch ein Bildschirm
zwischen zwei verschiedenen Rechner umschalten kannst.
Aber ich hab mir ein bisschen besseren gekauft,
der auch per Shortcut funktioniert.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie gut das...
Wie gut das...
Das zeige ich euch, wenn ich das Ding mal ausprobiert hab.
Nicht, dass ich euch das jetzt zeige und dann taugt das Ding nix.
Ich hab das Ding... Ich hab den KVM-Switch
hier noch in der Packung liegen.
Also, der ist von...
T... Was steht da? T-Smart steht da drauf.
T-Smart...
ToEnjoySmart, das sind irgendwelche
China-Chinesen-Hersteller. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, hab ich mir gekauft,
weil...
Shortcut umschalten und
weil der irgendwie so einen Fast-Switch-Modus hat.
Aber keine Ahnung,
ob das Ding was taugt. Achso, ja, und uns, weil es
USB-C-Anschlüsse hat.
Keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt.
Muss ich erst ausprobieren.
Automatischen für
HDMI kann ich nicht machen, ich habe beides an. Außerdem brauche ich
kein Display umschalten, weil ich hab
einen Monitor für das Notebook und einen für meinen Desktop.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, also...
Das ist echt
eine Sache, die mir auf der neuen Arbeit mega
auf den Sack geht. Dass die auf der
einen Seite mega bürokratisch sind
bei vielen Sachen, das ist aber
noch nicht mal das Nervigste. Das hat ja noch
durchaus, durchaus manchmal
seine Vorteile.
Aber,
dass die so mega restriktiv sind mit allem,
ist total hängen geblieben.
Ganz ehrlich, dass 90%
von ihrem restriktiven Kram
bräuchte man überhaupt nicht, wenn man einfach
einen Linux-Notebook benutzen könnte.
Die haben zum Beispiel auf ihren Windows-Notebooks,
es ist ohne Scheiß so, wenn du, wenn
ich bei meinem Arbeits-Notebook,
wenn ich dort, wenn ich dort hier unten
ausklappe,
wenn ich dort
hier unten ausklappe, das ist ja noch Windows 10,
das geht bis hier. Das ist kein
Spaß, Leute. Das ist wirklich kein Witz.
Die Anzahl der Icons
geht bis hier. Die geht bis zu den anderen
Icons vor. So viel Scheiße läuft da im Hintergrund.
Das ist wirklich kein
Witz jetzt.
50 Viren-Scanner und Security-Shit
und das bräuchtest du alles nicht,
hätten die Leute einfach einen Linux-Notebook.
Die haben da auch sowas, was beispielsweise nur
Whitelisted, deswegen kann ich auch Windows
nicht ernsthaft benutzen für irgendwas.
Ich hab eigentlich Windows nur als Terminal
offen und bin auf meiner Linux-VRM drauf.
Die haben auch so Sachen, dass
das Software Whitelisted werden muss.
Den ganzen Mist bräuchtest du nicht. Gib es einfach
Linux-Client. Das ist bei uns
tatsächlich auch so, witzigerweise.
Ich hab auch schon mal versucht,
das auszutricksen.
Ich hab das mal versucht auszutricksen und zwar
Ich hab mir gedacht, ey, weißt du was?
Wenn
das Notebook per VPN
auf die Arbeit kommt,
warum logge ich mich nicht einfach irgendwie
von meiner Linux-VRM auf den Notebook ein
vom Notebook dann dann weiter?
Die haben das wirklich so gemacht,
dass du
nur eine Netzwerkkarte aktiv
haben kannst und
wenn du VPN aufbaust,
ist diese Netzwerkkarte exklusiv
für VPN-Usage
reserviert.
Was auch schon ziemlich keck-weight ist.
Also ich sehe da aktuell keine Möglichkeit
das irgendwie auszutricksen.
Ja, das würde ich auch
nehmen. Würde ich sofort nehmen.
Du bräuchtest 90% dieser ganzen
Security-Sachen nicht,
weil unter Linux
hast du die Probleme halt nicht. Ja, das wird bei uns
nicht funktionieren, weil Whitelisted-Sachen
hat
nicht
das aktuelle Surface-Book.
Sowohl LTE
als auch Touch, als auch
Stift-Bedienung.
Also ich hatte auf der alten Arbeit
hatte ich ein Surface-Book,
das hatte Touch, das hatte glaube ich
auch eine SIM-Karte.
Ob du den
Bildschirm drehen konntest, weiß
ich nicht.
Gibt es aber bestimmt eine Surface-Book-Version mit einem drehbaren
Bildschirm.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Hehehe.
Das ist auch pfeifert.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Also ich hatte relativ lange
einen Surface-Book auf der alten Arbeit,
aber tatsächlich mit Linux drauf und das ging
ausgesprochen gut.
Ich habe auch keine
advanced Features verwendet, also ich habe keine
ansteckbare Grafikkarte
oder ja, Sleep
oder sonst was benutzt.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier heute auf YouTube?
Zu bieten.
Was wir uns angucken können.
Nein!
YouTube ist der Meinung, ich muss mir unbedingt
jedes
Keck-W-Video, was es nur gibt, anschauen.
Oh, das, das
gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall heute noch an.
Das gucke ich immer mega gerne.
Home-Automation-Beispiele,
was die Leute gebaut haben.
Powerbanks,
ein Einweg?
Was Powerbank aus Einweg
Vapes?
Das sind quasi E-Zigaretten mit Akku oder wie?
Warum?
Ich meine, man könnte einfach, wenn man eine Powerbank braucht,
sich eine Powerbank holen, oder?
Warum brauche ich eine Powerbank
aus
Einweg-E-Zigaretten, wenn ich einfach eine Powerbank
mir holen kann? Es ist jetzt ja nicht so,
als wäre irgend so eine x-beliebige
Powerbank so wahnsinnig
teuer, ja?
Okay, das interessiert mich aber tatsächlich jetzt.
Das müssen wir uns mal kurz anschauen.
Aber warum?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
E-Zigaretten, auch unter dem Markennamen...
Ach, ist das, dass man die einsammeln kann
und daraus eine Powerbank bauen, oder was?
Vielleicht recyclingmäßig?
Das stimmt. Das finde ich teilweise auch
ziemlich, ziemlich
nicht so pfeifert von den Leuten.
Wenn ich irgendwie über irgendwelche
Felder laufe, oder so auf
Feldwegen und so, sehe ich erstaunlich
oft irgendwelche Einweg-E-Zigaretten
rumliegen, oder E-Zigaretten rumliegen.
Elfbar bekannt.
Und daraus baue ich in diesem Video
eine wiederaufladbare Powerbank.
Guck mal hier, das ist ein ganzer Haufen leerer
Einweg-E-Zigaretten, auch
unter dem Markennamen Elfbar bekannt.
Und daraus baue ich in diesem
Video eine wiederaufladbare
Powerbank. Und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt,
hä, Einweg-E-Zigaretten, da sind
wiederaufladbare Akkus drin? Das ergibt
überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn man die nach dem Leerrauchen
gar nicht mehr benutzen kann. Ja, da habt ihr
vollkommen recht, das ist aber tatsächlich
so. Warum, das klären wir auch in diesem
Video. Und wenn ihr euch jetzt auch noch fragen,
nehmen sie mit? Nee.
Ich lauf doch nicht rum und sammel Dreck
im Feld ein.
Hä, aber warum denn Einweg?
Es gibt doch so wiederaufladbare Dinger,
wo man Liquid reinfüllen kann. Ja,
aber diese Einweg-Elfbars,
die sind leider trotzdem
ein riesen Ding. Ich hab hier in Hannover
mal random in 10 Kioske reingeguckt
und in jedem einzelnen... Warum?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, warum?
Warum Einweg-E-Zigaretten?
Ich mein, bei normalen Zigaretten
versteh ich's ja, die sind von Haus aus
Einweg. Ja?
Aber bei E-Zigaretten?
Ich mein, so eine Zigarette ist
danach halt weg, bis auf diesen Stummel
am Ende. Aber... E-Zigaretten?
Geld? Meint ihr, das ist
wirklich billiger, Einweg, als
sich so ein auffüllbares Ding zu kaufen?
Ist das billiger, wirklich?
Denn davon gab's die Dinger. Und laut
einer Recherche von Tomatolix
werden davon allein in Deutschland... Ja gut, wenn es
bequemer ist, dann versteh
ich das.
Bequemlichkeit ist ja prinzipiell
der Hauptfaktor, warum man Leute dazu
bekommt, seinen Service zu benutzen.
Monat drei bis vier...
Der Service muss nicht sicher sein oder sonst
was, der muss einfach nur bequem sein, schon werden ihn
die Leute benutzen. ...Millionenstück
verkauft. Und das ist nur die Aussage
von einem einzigen Distributor.
Es gibt noch mehr davon. Ja, und die Teile
werden inzwischen sogar von deutschen Rappern
wie Haftbefehl, Samrack und... Wait a minute!
Haftbefehl hat ne eigene E-Zigarette?
...davon. Ja, und die Teile
werden inzwischen sogar von deutschen Rappern
wie Haftbefehl...
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton
Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick
auf Sponsor.
Moment, es gibt Haftbefehl
Steve Jobs E-Zigarette?
Samrack und 187
Straßenbande vermarktet.
Und in jedem von diesen Dingern steckt
ein 360 bis 700
mAh Lithium-Ionen-Akku.
Akkus, die nicht dafür vorgesehen
sind, wieder aufgeladen zu werden.
Sondermüll ist das, da steht auch drauf,
seht ihr an der durchgestrichenen Mülltonne
da auf den Dingern. Man darf die Dinger auf
gar keinen Fall in den Hausmüll werfen.
Deswegen werfen die so viele Leute auch einfach
auf irgendwelche Feldwege. Das ist ja kein Hausmüll.
Und was glaubt ihr? Gehen die Millionen
Einweg-Vapes in Deutschland
alle in den Sondermüll? Ganz, ganz sicher
nicht. Also wirklich ne totale
Umweltsauerei, die ist meine Meinung
schleunigst verboten werden sollte.
So, aber jetzt versuchen wir aus dem Dreck
wenigstens noch was Sinnvolles zu machen.
Und was machen wir jetzt mit der Powerbank?
Ja klar, ein Raspi 4 plus Display
mit Stromversorgung. Und damit spielen.
Quasi ein Einweg-Zigaretten-
Do-it-yourself-Steamdeck.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackern und liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von Crowdsack.
Ah, ich dachte jetzt kommt NordVPN oder sowas wieder.
... von Crowdsack. Das ist eine
kollaborative Open-Source-Sicherheitssoftware,
die in der Lage ist, das Verhalten
eurer Website-Besucher zu...
Ehrlich gesagt, kenn ich nicht.
Kennt ihr das? ...analysieren und auf
alle Arten von Angriffen entsprechend
zu reagieren. Der Name dort...
Ich glaub, ich hab da auf Reddit schon mal Werbung für bekommen.
... freutet es schon an. Das Ganze ist Crowdsourced.
Das heißt, wenn eine IP-Adresse
geblockt wird, werden alle Community-Mitglieder
darüber informiert, sodass die die Adresse
auch blocken können. Crowdsourced?
Das heißt, der Inder für...
Der Pfeiffer-Inder sitzt dann da dran und tippt das ein.
Crowdsack ist einfach
zu installieren und lässt sich dann über die
Crowdsack-Konsole steuern. Zurzeit
wird das kostenlose Cyber-Threat-Intelligence-Tool
in über 180 Ländern
eingesetzt und die Community hat bereits
über 40 Millionen bösartige IPs
angezeigt. Crowdsack kann nicht nur
Server schützen, sondern natürlich auch
VMs oder Container. Guckt euch das doch mal an.
Die URL ist in der Beschreibung
verlinkt. Erbung Ende.
Wir haben hier eine ganze Tüte
voll mit diesen Dingern
und Andrean natürlich. Andrean
kennt sich mit Löten aus, ich nicht so.
Und Andrean sagt, diese
Schnapsidee aus diesen Dingern
eine Powerbank zu machen, das geht irgendwie.
Aber ganz zuerst noch mal,
warum in aller Welt ist
in diesen Einweg-E-Zigaretten,
warum machen die da nicht eine
AA-Batterie rein?
Also warum da ein wiederaufladbarer Akku drin ist,
das frage ich mich tatsächlich auch.
Da sind bestimmt irgendwelche
Regulatorien oder so.
Warum ist da so ein teurer Akku drin?
Also meine naheliegendste Vermutung war,
dass die Lithium-Akkus verwenden, weil
ich für diese Heizspirale in diesen
Einweg-Zigaretten einen recht hohen Strom
benötige. Und sowas liefern diese kleinen
Batterien normalerweise nicht,
sondern ich habe hier eben eine Lithium-Batterie,
die kann das und natürlich kriegt man alles irgendwie
mit einer gewissen Leistung heiß, aber wenn ich da
entsprechend viel Dampf rauskriegen will, was ich ja haben will,
dann brauche ich schon so um die
10 bis 15 Watt, je nachdem.
Hast du so ein Ding schon mal aufgemacht?
Ich habe so ein Ding schon mal aufgemacht, deswegen habe ich auch schon eine Batterie in der Hand.
Einfach so? Einfach dran ziehen, genau.
Ah, das ist krass, das ist ja total einfach.
So, und dann hat man hier so ein schwammartiges
Material, da ist wahrscheinlich...
Das ist ja total einfach, na gut, ich meine,
dass die Dinger nicht die beste Build-Quality haben
als Einweg-Zigarette, ist doch klar.
Die Nikotin-Plörre reingetunkt,
genau, und dann haben wir hier genau noch so einen Schwamm,
der ist noch davor, und jetzt müssten wir gleich
zum Akku vordringen.
Gute Knepperzange. Dieser Schwamm
ist mit Liquid getränkt,
genau, der ist auch richtig nass.
Das klebt ziemlich egal.
So, dann haben wir so eine Hülse, und jetzt kommt
hier... Verdampfer, also...
Ah ja, okay.
Erst mal schön antatschen
alles.
So ein Todesinsekt.
Wir haben das Ding jetzt auseinandergebaut,
was ist denn das jetzt? Also hier, das ist die
Unterseite, ne? Genau, das ist die Unterseite,
die haben wir gerade mit dem Schraubendreher rausgehauen.
Meine Theorie ist, wir haben das jetzt natürlich nicht verifiziert,
dass hier ein kleiner integrierter Schaltkreis drin ist,
mit einem Druckschalter,
der dann dafür sorgt, dass am Ende
zu der Heizspirale,
zu dieser Glühwende,
durchgeschaltet wird, dass dort also Hitze entsteht.
Also, Druckschalter meinst du unter Druck,
also wenn man saugt, sozusagen.
Merkst du ja auch, wenn du daran saugst...
Dann geht auch die LED an, die da unten drin ist, ne?
Die LED geht an, du musst ein bisschen Kraft aufbringen,
damit das funktioniert,
und dann schaltet der durch und wird hier
die Glühwende in diesem Liquid-Tank
erhitzen,
sodass du dann am Ende den Dampf da rauskriegst.
Ich habe mir so ein Ding ja gerade auseinandergebaut,
weil es so stinkt, dieses Liquid,
immer noch, ziehe ich mir jetzt zumindest mal
Handschuhe an.
Es ist ja auch nicht wirklich dafür gedacht,
daran rumzuhantieren.
Das ist echt eklig, das klebt und es stinkt.
Du hast mir ja gerade schon erklärt, warum die
wahrscheinlich so einen umweltschädlichen Akku
benutzen. Wie ist das denn so, dein
Einschätzung zu diesem Produkt?
Naja, also,
wenn ich frei sprechen darf,
dann, das ist eine riesige
Umweltsauerei. Also, Lithium ist
ja nicht pauschal umweltschädlich, sondern
nur, wenn man es zum Beispiel in solchen Konstellationen
einfach in den Restmüll wirft,
hinzukommt. Ja, oder auf
irgendeinen Waldweg wegschmeißt.
Wie gesagt, ich sehe total oft solche Dinger
irgendwo auf dem Feld liegen, auf dem Weg liegen.
Das ist ja auch, also auch dieser
Mantel, der hier, dieses Gehäuse, was ja aus
Metall ist, dass das Ressourcen sind, die wir
eigentlich... Ich meine, aktuell ist es eh schon
keine gute Idee, im Sommer normale
Zigaretten wegzuschmeißen im Wald, gerade
wenn es trocken ist.
Da fackelt dir dann der Wald
irgendwann ab. E-Zigaretten
fackelt dir zwar nicht der Wald von
ab, aber es ist trotzdem keine gute Idee, die einfach
wegzuschmeißen.
Also, es ist gar nicht förderlich, dass die so
weggeworfen werden. Was wir jetzt machen,
wir bauen jetzt aus den ganzen Dingern
die Akkus aus und dann versuchen wir dann
eine Powerbank mitzubauen, gucken...
Das wäre mir viel zu anstrengend.
Ja, ich könnte sicherlich auch
nach ein paar Wochen hätte ich genug zusammen,
wenn ich die sammeln würde.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich sehe öfters welche, da hätte ich
bestimmt auch genug zusammen, um eine Powerbank...
Aber das wäre mir, ganz ehrlich, das wäre mir
der Stress.
Es ist ja eher so
ein Bastelprojekt, aber das wäre mir
der Aufwand nicht wert.
Und am Ende können wir dann
zumindest die Akkus dann in die
Batterie-Entsorgungs-
Kästen, die in Supermärkten
und so stehen, tun. Genau, das ist ja auch
das... Wie lange braucht er denn, um den Handschuh
anzuziehen? Das Schlimme daran ist, es ist ja wirklich
eine Einmal-E-Zigarette.
Wer jetzt rauchen möchte, soll das meinetwegen
tun, aber es gibt ja
Alternativen, wo ich zum Beispiel so eine
normale 18650-Lithium-Zelle
reintun kann. Die kann ich austauschen. Ist die
Zelle kaputt, tausche ich die Zelle aus, ist die E-Zigarette kaputt.
Es gibt auch solche... Jetzt hat er es
aufgegeben mit dem Handschuh.
Reicht jetzt. Zigaretten sind genau dem
Formfaktor. Also das macht natürlich auch
süchtig wie Sau, also Nikotin,
na klar. Niemals kaufen, wenn
ihr sowas gerne benutzen wollt, dann
kauft euch was anderes. Wir wollen
aber jetzt einfach mal zeigen... Viele glauben
das einfach, viele glauben das einfach gar nicht.
Leute, die Elfbars benutzen, dass das...
Guck mal, jetzt versteckt er schon die Hand mit dem Handschuh.
Das ist ein
normaler Akku, der da drin ist. Ich habe tatsächlich
Händler gefunden, die sowas verkaufen. Ich habe
nicht genau den gefunden mit den 360
mAh, aber dadurch, dass das hier
3,7 Volt nominal sind, gehe ich davon
aus, es ist eine Lithium-Zelle, die wir aufladen. Ja,
3,7 Volt haben die Dinge, aber glaube
ich auch nur, wenn sie richtig voll sind.
Ich glaube, die gehen bis 4,2.
Kann das sein? Weil ich habe
mich damit mal temporär
beschäftigt, als ich
einen ESP32 mal
mit Akku betreiben wollte.
Ich glaube, die gehen maximal, wenn
sie komplett voll sind, rauf bis
4,2. Und
ja, dann am Ende haben sie
so irgendwas 2,8 oder sowas
Volt. Also sprich,
du kannst damit
einen ESP32
ganz gut betreiben,
ohne irgendwelche
Regelungen dazwischen,
wenn
der halbwegs gescheit gemacht ist.
...laden können. Und wir löten das
jetzt einfach mal zusammen und haben hier so
eine Powerbank-Platine und versuchen das dann mal aufzuladen.
Und die Powerbank-Platine, was
macht die? Das ist ein stinknormaler Laderegler,
der einerseits
eine kontrollierte Ladung für Lithium-Akkus
liefert. Das heißt, ich schließe hier zum Beispiel,
also im Normalfall wäre das dann zum Beispiel so
ein Block, so ein 10-Ampere-Stunden-Block.
Die löte ich hier ganz normal ab.
Und dann kann ich hier per Micro-USB anschließen,
das aufladen und power dann wieder raus.
Genau, so ein Teil habe ich auch,
wenn man sich ein Low-Power
ESP32-Board kauft, zum Beispiel
sowas,
dann haben die so eine
Ladeschaltung schon mit onboard.
Zum Beispiel der hier, das Ding ist
richtig nice, wenn man Low-Power-Projekte
basteln möchte auf
ESP32-Basis.
Die Dinger verbrauchen fast nichts
im Deep Sleep, also die Boards.
Also, der
D1 Mini beispielsweise auch sehr beliebt ist,
der verbraucht viel zu viel im Sleep.
Und die haben unten, oder
ne, mittlerweile haben die sogar hier einen extra Anschluss
für den Akku und
Ladeelektronik mit drinnen.
Und hier kann man auch theoretisch einen Akku anlöten,
ja.
Und das Ding sorgt dafür, dass das Teil
nicht überladen wird und uns um die Ohren fliegt,
sozusagen. Und dein Plan ist jetzt
aus den E-Zigaretten
die Akkus raus zu bröseln
und die dann einfach in Reihe
an die beiden Drähte dran zu
löten, sozusagen. Parallel, weil
wenn wir die in Reihe schalten würden, dann wäre die
Gefahr des Überladens doch relativ hoch,
ne, und wir, dadurch, dass wir hier schon 3,7
Moment, Chat, Chat, Elektronikors
jetzt im Chat,
wenn man die in Reihe aneinander
lötet, heißt das, oder so
in Serie heißt das nicht, heißt das nicht in Serie?
Ach, was auch immer. Wären dann nicht
auch der, die Spannung,
müsste man dann nicht auch die Spannung
zusammenzählen? Also,
wären das dann nicht, keine Ahnung,
3,5 Volt plus 3,5
Volt, 7 Volt und am Ende wird das Ding einfach
kaputt gehen? Wohingegen
parallel die Spannung gleich
bleibt? Ja, ne?
Ich erinnere mich da dunkel.
7 Volt haben, schalten
wir die jetzt einfach alle parallel, baust die auseinander,
ich löte ne Runde und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Was, andersrum? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Und was wäre jetzt genau die Gefahr, wenn wir die in Reihe
schalten würden? Da ist die Gefahr,
dass möglicherweise einzelne
Zellen langsamer anders
geladen werden müssen und wenn ich dann
einfach weiter von außen Strom hinzugebe
und einfach versuche, die Ladeschlussspannung
zu erreichen, dann kann es passieren, dass einzelne
Zellen überladen werden, während andere
noch gar nicht fertig sind. Ja, Lithium-Akkus
zu überladen kann unterschiedliche Effekte
haben, von irgendwelchen Schutzschaltungen,
die abschalten, bis hin zu... Oh, das fackelt ab.
Die gehen in Flammen auf oder gasen aus,
je nachdem. Das zeigen wir jetzt mal einmal ganz kurz,
was eigentlich passiert, wenn man so ein
Teil kurz schließt. Nur mal so kurz
als Warnung, ne? Dass ihr Bescheid wisst.
Ja, und weil
das hier um die сумme geht...
Ja, jetzt übertreibt
halt! Man sieht halt zwei Batterien
ein bisschen brennen.
Bei der Musik denkst du...
Ach nee, gleich explodieren sie vielleicht noch.
Ja, übertreibt!
Jetzt starten wir mal.
Nicht wirklich viel passiert.
Schön bunt!
Oh,
Banane!
Ja, also der Fachleute Adrian hat jetzt
23... Ich glaube
Das würden wir auch hinkriegen, ohne Fachlöter zu sein.
Von den Dingern da aufgelötet. Ich glaube, das reicht erstmal für unser Experiment.
Und das sieht wunderbar aus. Das sieht richtig aus wie Fluxkompensator.
Jetzt könnte man damit irgendwie in die Zukunft reisen oder so.
Also wir haben jetzt hier diesen Controller und da schließen wir Mikro-USB-Kabeln an.
Genau, ich löte das jetzt gleich noch da an und dann schließen wir das an zusammen mit dem USB-Messgerät und dann können wir auch gleich gucken, ob das lädt.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
So und in diesem aufregenden Moment nochmal einmal der Disclaimer.
Macht das nicht zu Hause nach. Wir haben das jetzt gerade hier noch so ein bisschen zusammengefrickelt, um euch das mal zu zeigen.
Um zu zeigen, die sind aufladbar, das ist Energie. Wir wissen nicht genau, von welchem Hersteller die sind.
Sag mal Leute, von der Farbe her. Ist das eine Weller-Lötstation?
So von der Farbe her sieht das irgendwie ein bisschen so aus.
Haben die nicht so dieses Hellblau?
Gerade hier noch so ein bisschen zusammengefrickelt, um euch das mal zu zeigen.
Das sind die Dinger, die Ultra-Lötstation sind.
Die sind aufladbar, das ist Energie. Wir wissen nicht genau, von welchem Hersteller die sind.
Es kann sein, dass die wirklich nur für einmalige, zweimalige, dreimalige Nutzung geeignet sind.
Es besteht Brandgefahr. Tut's lieber nicht.
So, ich steck das da jetzt rein.
Ja, steck das da mal rein und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Das ist aufregend.
Ja.
Aufregend.
Es lädt.
Jetzt blinkt das. Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich, dass es lädt.
Also, wir laden jetzt hier gerade mit drei, mit vier Watt. Mit vier Watt laden wir gerade.
Wir warten jetzt, bis der Rotz aufgeladen ist und dann schließen wir nochmal irgendwas an diese Powerbank an.
Gucken, wie lange wir da irgendwas mit betreiben können.
Ja, genau. Wir schauen einfach mal, wie viele Wattstunden wir jetzt noch rauskriegen.
Also, du meinst, die anderen sind auch teuer, aber taugen nix.
Also, ich habe nicht vor, mir eine neue Lötstation zu kaufen.
Ich habe aber auch keine Vorbereitung.
Ich habe eine von Vella. Ich habe eine von Esra oder so.
Äh.
Ersa.
Muss ich gerade mal kurz draufgucken.
Ist das nicht China-Chinesen-Kram?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Das sieht sehr ähnlich zu dem aus, was ich habe.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist das Teil.
Also, was ich an der mag, ist halt erstens austauschbare Spitze.
Ähm.
Und was ich cool finde.
Was ich cool finde, dass der, ich muss mal kurz zeigen, ja, hier sieht man es halbwegs, was ich cool finde, dass die so ein flexibel, so ein flexibles Kabel haben.
Also, du merkst eigentlich gar nicht großartig, also der Lötkolben ist sehr leicht und du hast ein flexibles Kabel.
Also, es kommt dir nicht in die Quere.
Und, und, und ja, du kannst das Ding irgendwo nebenhin stellen und brauchst eigentlich nur das hier auf dem Tisch.
Das ist eigentlich echt gut durchdacht.
Agiles Kabel.
Ob die überhaupt tatsächlich aufladbar war.
Noch, noch brennt nichts.
Noch Gas nichts.
Aus.
Von Angst, ne?
Ja, wir haben jetzt unsere 11-Paar-Powerbank, haben wir jetzt geladen.
Wir wollten sie eigentlich über Nacht laden lassen, aber als ich dann nach Hause gefahren bin, habe ich einen kleinen Panikanfall gekriegt und dachte, ich fackele den ganzen Verlag ab.
Und dann haben wir das doch nicht über Nacht laufen lassen.
Das heißt, die Akkus...
Ja, so selbst gebasteltes Zeug ist immer keine allzu schlaue Idee, über Nacht, ohne dass irgendjemand da ist.
Sind jetzt so vier Stunden, würde ich sagen.
Unbeauschtlich zu laden.
Vier, fünf, sechs Stunden und jetzt sind sie, glaube ich, halb voll.
Es reicht ja, um auszuprobieren.
Und ich habe hier meine tolle Raspi-Installation.
Das ist ein Raspi 4 mit so einem kleinen Display.
Display habe ich jetzt im Moment noch normal am Strom hängen, weil das die Powerbank eventuell...
Ja, Patrick, hat er bei mir auch.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Wenn ich schaffe, das probieren wir gleich nochmal aus.
Aber der Raspi, der wird jetzt komplett von den E-Zigaretten-Akkus gepowert.
Hoffe ich.
Und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ja.
Leider verbrauchen Raspberry Pi ein bisschen zu viel, dass ich das praktikabel an der Batterie betreiben lässt.
Oh.
Also ich hatte es mal ausgerechnet.
Ich glaube, an so einer normalen 0815 Powerbank läuft ein Raspberry Pi Idle, glaube ich, fünf, sechs Stunden.
Sorry?
Ja, hör mal.
Da kommen ganz normal fünf Volt raus, wenn man sie einschaltet.
So.
Okay.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Die Raspi-LED ist an.
Der zielt ungefähr fünf Watt.
Das Display geht an.
Krass.
Naja, wundert mich nicht.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt kein großer Unterschied zu irgendeinem normalen Powerbank, sondern die Dinger sehen innen ähnlich aus.
Ja, fünf Volt, 1,1 Ampere.
Oh, ist das eine Fehlermeldung?
Under Voltage detected.
Okay, das ist aber vielleicht nicht so schlimm.
Könnte sein, dass er trotzdem bootet.
Bootet doch.
Ja, das Ding bootet, aber wahrscheinlich kann es sein, wenn du es ordentlich belastest, dass er den dann abkackt.
Oh, das ist ja überraschend.
Ja.
Ich hätte mir gerne jetzt ein Spiel gespielt, das was mit Rauchen zu tun hat, aber haben wir nicht gefunden.
Dann taktet er sich dann vielleicht runter oder so.
Keine Ahnung, wie es der Raspberry Pi verhält.
Jetzt versuche ich auch noch das Display.
Okay, easy.
Wir wissen, dass man aus Wegwerf-Akkus eine Powerbank bauen kann.
Gut, das habe ich mir vorher auch schon gedacht.
Was mich nur tatsächlich auch gewundert hat, ist, dass da wiederaufladbare Akkus drin sind.
... aus mobiles Gaming sind.
... zusagen.
... aufentsorgen.
Ähm, wir haben ja nicht herausgefunden, wer eigentlich der Herr ist.
Das war jetzt nicht so spannend.
All Japanese schools dumpest rules in one video.
Okay.
Ayaya time.
Warum soll ich mir jetzt Regeln für japanische Schulen angucken?
Es ist nicht so, als würde ich demnächst in Japan in die Schule gehen, aber es scheinen viele zu interessieren.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die machen komische Sachen.
Microservices.
Ich glaube, das Video kenne ich.
... die 10 Kreaturen an einem Tag sehen ...
... aber es ist nicht so einfach, okay?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das kenne ich.
Ich verstehe es immer noch nicht. Warum ist es so schwer, das Gebärde-Dad auf der Seite zu zeigen ...
Jaja, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich. Das ist das, wo er jetzt an der Tafel gleich seine hunderttausend Microservices erklärt,
und dass der eine auf den anderen zugreifen muss, dass er sich zum Authentifizieren und sowas.
... Geddingspage, warum können wir das dieses Wochenende nicht erreichen?
Weißt du was, ich bin es, wir haben es überdreht. Es ist das Design unsere Rückend.
Zuerst müssen wir den Bingo Service anrufen.
Sieh, Bingo kennt alle Names, damit wir die Id 라는 der Anwender erfahren.
Da ist er.
Das ist eine Sache, muss man sagen, ist tatsächlich relativ realitätsnah,
dass alles irgendwelche komischen Code-Wörter bzw. Projektnamen braucht
oder aber, wenn man zu blöd ist, sich Projektnamen auszudenken,
dann kürzt man alles ab.
Also dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, die machen beides.
Die denken sich Projektnamen aus und kürzen sie dann ab.
Das läuft dann darauf raus, dass das aktuelle Projekt,
in dem ich hauptsächlich aktuell tätig bin,
vier verschiedene Namen hat, ohne Scheiß.
Vier verschiedene Namen, vier verschiedene Abkürzungen.
Und je nachdem, wer davon redet, in welcher Art, heißt das anders.
Obwohl die alle das Gleiche meinen.
Raccoon ist nicht garantiert, dass er diese Info hat.
Bevor wir das tun, müssen wir nach Wingman gehen
und eine Query machen, um zu sehen, ob der Anwender es auf den nächsten Niveau nehmen will
oder ob sie nur im Feld spielen.
Wingman ist cool, aber er stört keine User-Info selbst.
Er muss sich an andere User-Info-Provider-Services anmelden,
wie RGS, Barbie Doll, Ringo 2, BLS.
Aber wie weiß er, was alle User-Provider-Services sind?
Für das muss er an Galactus gehen,
einen allmählichen User-Service-Provider-Aggregator.
Und obwohl Galactus das unnötige Wissen aller aktuellen User-Info-Providern hat,
hat er keine Zukunfts-Seite oder Wissen von früheren User-Info-Providern,
also erwartet er einen Zeitraum.
Um alle aktuellen User-Info-Providern zu bekommen,
müssen wir einen Zeitraum mit dem aktuellen Zeitraum
und einem Zeitraum, der das Ende des Universums repräsentiert.
Was wir von EKS bekommen,
unserem Entry-Chaos-Service.
EKS wird am Ende des Monats für Omegastar geprägt,
aber Omegastar unterstützt noch nicht ISO-Zeiträume,
wie sie es vor einem Monat gesagt haben.
Also bis Omegastar ihre verdammte Scheiße zusammenhält,
sind wir blockiert.
Wir können nicht für unseren Anwendungsfall anrufen,
wir können EKS nicht nutzen,
es gibt nichts, was wir tun können.
Also wird Galactus nicht die Möglichkeit haben,
unsere neue Website zu finden,
wir haben einen neuen Birthday-Boy-Provider,
was bedeutet,
Wingman weiß nicht, wie man mit jemandem sprechen kann,
ich werde nicht die Möglichkeit haben, echte Liebe zu finden
und ich werde allein sterben.
Ich werde allein sterben.
Ohne das Liebe zu wissen.
Ohne das zu wissen, dass es mein Geburtstag ist.
Wir sind blockiert, okay?
Wir sind blockiert,
du trauriger, pathetischer kleiner Produktmanager.
Du denkst, du weißt, was unsere User wollen?
Du weißt nichts von meinem Schmerz.
Von Galactus' Schmerz.
Du denkst, du weißt, was es dauert,
um dem User zu sagen, dass es ihr Geburtstag ist?
Du weißt nichts.
Der Anwendung dieses Features geht gegen alles,
was ich kenne, um richtig und wahr zu sein.
Und ich werde dich künftig
in diese verdammte Erde legen,
und dann dein Verlust für einen Moment länger unterdrehen.
Okay, also klar, das ist ein Blocker.
Kein Problem, wir werden das in 2-3 Jahren noch ausbauen.
Wir haben heute viel gelernt.
Wir lieben Galactus.
Aber wir sprechen nächste Woche darüber,
ob wir den Profil mit Mittelnamen einsetzen können.
Toll, klingt gut.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Oh, Moment.
Wollen wir Package-Updates mal machen,
wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind?
Zack.
Oh, hier.
Highway wird geupdatet.
Was auch immer.
Manchmal frage ich mich ernsthaft,
was ich da alles installiert habe.
Was ist Highway?
C++...
Was ist das?
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
Warum habe ich eine C++-Library
für Dings hier, Simt, installiert?
Na gut, komm.
Aber updaten darf er sie.
Und da macht er gleich noch Kernel-Updates mit,
was natürlich besonders poggers ist.
Weil wenn er Kernel-Updates mitmacht,
dann muss ich eh neu starten.
Gibt es hier Updates?
Oh, Updating ist ja gut.
Dann update dich mal.
So, das ist fertig.
Jawohl, auch updaten, alles updaten.
Gibt es hier irgendwelche Updates?
Nope.
Wunderbar.
Perfekt.
So, dann können wir rebooten.
Hm.
Hast du schon den AA-Assist in den Chat?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher.
Muss man sich da irgendwie nochmal extra registrieren?
Ich meine, ich habe einen All-Desktop-Package.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das da dabei ist.
Ja, komm, gleich gucken.
Ich will jetzt erst mal rebooten.
Wobei, was ist das hier?
So, Randy's new JavaScript-Package,
Squeakle.js,
is transforming the Internet
by adding a fourth equal sign.
What is it?
Moment, was?
Ist das in Ernst?
Ist das wirklich ein echtes GitHub-Projekt?
Ich meine, ich traue dem mittlerweile alles zu.
Do.
The fourth equal sign can infer developer intent
from the surrounding code.
It's designed for brand new programmers
who have no idea what they're doing
and advanced programmers
Okay, nee, ist G-Bait, aber ...
and more years of JavaScript experience.
What about all the rest?
Randy doesn't care about those people.
In fact, Squeakle.js keeps re-overwriting $
to fuck with what he calls the jQuery .
What?
The fourth equal sign has two ...
Wisst ihr, das Schlimme ist?
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass Leute sich irgendwas ausdenken an JavaScript-Libraries,
was wirklich ein viertes Gleichheitszeichen braucht.
Wobei, ich glaube,
man kann das rein über Library-Sachen
nicht einbauen in JavaScript.
Das ist ja quasi Core-Syntax.
Das passt da nicht richtig.
... figures out what you probably wanted
and just does that.
It can do stuff like compare a byte array
containing a video of a person holding up fingers
to an integer.
Imagine the potential.
I guess I could see ...
If you add parentheses ...
Hä?
Und um was geht's da jetzt?
Also den initialen Joke hab ich gegettet,
aber danach ...
Jetzt auf, Mann!
Mach halt mal Update!
Was braucht der denn da so lang schon wieder?
Was ist denn das?
Oh.
Er muss irgendwas zippen.
Alles klar.
Na gut.
Dann zippe mal.
Jetzt, fertig gezippt.
Auf.
Hopp, hopp.
Ich will einfach nur rebooten.
Ich hab zu viele ...
Ich hab zu viele Icons installiert.
Das dauert drei Stunden.
Warum hab ich eigentlich so viele Icons installiert?
Es ist jetzt nicht so,
als bräuchte ich bei mir im Terminal oder im Browser,
sondern ich viele Icons.
Warum hab ...
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Warum hab ich überhaupt irgendwelche Icon-Packs installiert?
Ich benutze nirgendswo ...
Doch!
Im ...
In meinem File-Express.
Das ist das einzige, wo ich Icons verwende.
So.
Betriebssystem, Icons.
Oh nein, Passwort-Leak, Leute.
Haben wir es jetzt?
Brake.
Ist es fertig?
Ja.
So.
Okay.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Das ist ...
Huna ist das als File-Manager gewesen.
Aber ich benutze den eigentlich nie.
Ich benutze den nur,
wenn mein GUI File-Manager braucht,
nämlich,
zum rauskopieren aus der VM.
Das muss man irgendwie mit dem GUI File-Manager machen,
weil das sonst VMs ja nicht checkt.
Reinkopieren in die VM kannst du auch übers Terminal,
aber rauskopieren kannst du ...
kannst du nur gescheit mit dem GUI File-Manager.
Also guck.
Kannst du, ja, zum Beispiel ...
Ich zeig dir das.
Ja.
Passwort-Leak, Leute.
Nicht verraten, okay?
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
hier was rauskopieren will
aus der VM, dann geht das
nur, wenn ich das über...
Ja, super.
Dann geht das nur, wenn ich das hier drüber mache.
Ihr versteht, ja?
Und ich weiß nicht...
Wow, was ist denn hier los?
Und ich weiß nicht so genau, warum das ist, aber
okay, man...
Man muss halt irgendwie track und droppen, dass es funktioniert.
Hoch...
Best-Practice-Passwort, würde ich sagen.
Das ist eines der weit verbreitetsten
Passwörter weltweit. Das kann nicht schlecht sein.
Sonst würden das nicht so viele benutzen.
Oh, 44 Minuten, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Ja, das wollte ich mir angucken, genau.
Menschentiere-Automationen.
Vermutlich super
out of context, aber ich überlege
mir C++...
Der Satz, der so schon anfängt,
der ist schon...
Okay, lesen wir mal weiter.
Vermutlich so, aber ich überlege
mir C++ für die Unreal...
Ja, okay, Unreal hast du ja keine andere Möglichkeit,
wenn du an Unreal
in Reihen rumbasteln möchtest.
Was denkst du, wie viel Zeit dies in Anspruch nehmen würde?
Also, C++ ordentlich zu lernen
ist eine Lebensaufgabe.
Allerdings im Kontext
von Unreal...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, davon.
Also, kann ich...
Ich mache selbst
keine Spieleentwicklung,
noch kenne ich mich mit Unreal aus.
Aber ich denke mal, für den Kontext,
für Unreal, sollte C++
wahrscheinlich halbwegs machbar sein,
weil die wahrscheinlich, das rate ich jetzt einfach mal,
nicht, dass ich davon großartig Ahnung hätte,
wahrscheinlich
nicht den ganzen Shit verwenden,
den C++ eigentlich noch so bietet.
Sondern sie werden wahrscheinlich
das benutzen, was sie selbst für sinnig halten
und den anderen Krams einfach links liegen lassen.
Also dürfte das wahrscheinlich
durchaus machbar sein.
Das Problem ist wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr das C++-Lernen
für Unreal, sondern Unreal-Lernen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da so sagen kann.
Wichtig, gibt es mittlerweile auch Möglichkeiten,
Unreal mit etwas anderem zu programmieren als C++?
Ich meine, ja, man kann diese
Blueprint-Editor-Geschichte benutzen,
aber dann muss das da alles
GUI-mäßig machen.
Gibt es nicht auch vielleicht
JavaScript?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich glaube...
Alter, ich glaube, mein Windows hat gerade Updates
gemacht.
Auf dem zweiten Rechner. Einfach mal random.
Updates durchgeführt.
Warum macht es denn
sowas?
Geht mir schon ein wenig auf den Keks.
War da nicht was mit JavaScript?
Doch, kann schon sein.
Was für YouTube-Videos schaust du privat
eigentlich ohne Stream?
Und schon mal aufs Handy gucken.
Alle möglichen Sachen.
Guck jetzt einfach mal in meine Watch-History.
Also hauptsächlich Technik-Kram.
Und Sachen, wo man gut bei schlafen kann.
Also was ich...
Ein Channel, den ich gerne gucke,
den wir aber hier im Stream relativ selten...
gucken, ist...
...den hier. Den gucke ich recht gerne.
Vor allem, weil der oftmals
so Oldschool-Shit hat.
Wie zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Irgendwelche beschriftbaren
CD-Dinger. Der hat oftmals
richtig Oldschool-Kram. Was ich von dem auch gerne
gucke, ist...
Wir bauen uns den Traumrechner von 1998
und sowas.
Aber das ist halt, weil ich Boomer bin.
Ja.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn für eine Ausgeburt
der Hölle, Alter?
Was hat er da am Start?
Windows Vista-Bild.
Es gibt wirklich Leute...
Also bei ihm frage ich mich halt immer,
was der am Ende macht.
Mit dem Zeug, ne?
Was das da oben rechts für ein Controller ist?
Gute Frage.
Chat, ich muss mal meinen Stream-Vorschau-Rechner
kurz starten.
Der macht komische Dinger.
Der hat, glaube ich, gerade einen
Grafikkartentreiber-Update im Hintergrund
gemacht und
macht jetzt komische
Dinger. Ich muss meinen Vorschau-Rechner mal kurz
neu starten. Das heißt, ich muss hier in den Chat gucken.
Winamp. Ja, Winamp
ist eh das Beste.
Winamp?
Wie geht das? Llamas?
S? Ne, wie geht dieser
Winamp-Spruch? Winamp?
S? Long?
Lama? Irgendwas mit Lama.
Ich meine, das Ding ist schon
übertrieben, ne?
So, ich muss mal kurz die Tastatur umstöpseln.
Blum, blum, blum, blum.
Blum, blum, blum.
Winamp kickst
die Llamas erst irgendwie sowas. Genau, ja.
Irgendwie sowas.
Name geändert, aha.
Ich hätte es mir fast schon gedacht.
So, ich muss mal kurz den
Vorschau-Rechner wieder einschalten.
So.
Zack, zack.
Gott, wunderbar.
Exzellent.
Ähm, Leute, ich muss mal kurz pinkeln.
Danach gucken wir uns hier,
gucken wir weiter an. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Pepo, Pepo
Toilet-Zoom.
Geht schnell.
So. Wieder am Start.
Weiter geht's.
Eure Smart Home-Beispiele.
Menschentiere-Automation.
Ja, die Videos guckst du immer gern.
Wieder soweit. Wir holen uns Inspiration.
Bin ich mal gespannt. Das letzte Mal,
kann ich mich auch dran erinnern,
war ja da was richtig abgedrehtes dabei,
was ich mega nice fand,
aber so nie bauen würde.
Und zwar, da hat, genau das hier.
Von dem.
Das hier.
Das letzte Mal hat er doch den, den,
Moment, wo ist der Rasenmäher?
Hier.
Der Rasenmäher, der, der aus diesem,
das fand ich mega nice gemacht.
Auch wenn ich's mir im Leben nicht selbst in den Garten bauen würde,
sowas, mal ganz davon abgesehen, das ist mir viel zu aufwendig.
Und, äh, die Mähroboter funktionieren eh nicht richtig
bei mir im Garten, dank der ganzen Baumwurzeln und sowas.
Ich nehme auch mal stark an, dass das Kunstrasen ist,
der da oben drauf liegt.
Das, das fand ich, das fand ich ne richtig coole Sache.
Sehr kleine Grasnabel.
Und jetzt fährt er wieder runter.
Genau.
Das, das, das fand ich schon cool gemacht, ja.
Nicht so supergroß, das ist, das ist natürlich
schon eigentlich ne sehr elegante Geschichte.
Ja, das, das fand ich cool.
So, mal schauen, was es heute gibt.
... dazu, was wir in unseren Wohnungen
und Häusern und vor allem Gärten alles automatisieren können.
Wir gucken, was ihr so im Garten macht,
was sich sonst so für den Urlaub automatisieren lässt,
denn das ist heute die Urlaubsfolge.
Ihr seht es an meinem Outfit und ich würde sagen,
ich mach sogar noch einen Knopf auf.
Oder auch nicht.
Vor allem nutze ich natürlich eure Einsendung,
um dieses Video voll zu bekommen,
damit ich es veröffentlichen kann,
wenn ich vielleicht mal im Urlaub die Füße hochlegen möchte.
Es ist quasi eine doppelte Urlaubsfolge.
Oder so.
Vom Wasserfass über alternative Bewässerung
zu Hasen und Paketkästen.
Und jede gezeigte Automation bekommt wie immer
einen Amazon-Gutschein im Wert von 50 Euro
und ich kann eine Woche vorarbeiten,
weil ich einfach eure Arbeit
nutze.
Menschen, Tiere, Automation, Ausgabe 20.
Los geht's mit Dennis.
Und der hat uns eine Gartenbewässerung
und Automation geschickt.
Was gibt es mehr für den Urlaub geeignetes als das?
Wasser kommt jetzt zur Zeit nicht mehr genügend vom Himmel.
Also habe ich einen Brunnen gebohrt und hole es aus der Erde.
Den kann ich noch nicht fertigen.
Einfach mal einen Brunnen gebohrt. Easy.
Ja.
Macht man ja mal so nebenbei.
Im Brunnenstube befindet sich ein Gardena Hauswasserautomat,
der im Standby läuft.
Brunnenstube?
Ist das das Wort, das ich hätte googeln müssen,
um rauszufinden, ob es sowas gibt?
Also ich gehe davon aus, der Typ weiß, was er macht,
weil sonst wüsste er nicht, dass das Brunnenstube heißt.
Hat das Wort von euch jemals schon jemand gehört?
...fertig zu kaufen gibt.
Und sobald Wasser gefordert wird, springt dieser um
und fängt an zu pumpen, also fördert Wasser aus dem Brunnen nach oben.
Die Pumpe ist mittlerweile bei mir seit über drei Jahren im Einsatz
und wirklich ein gutes Teil, sofern man daran denkt,
die im Winter auch reinzuholen und somit vor Frost zu schützen.
Was soll das denn jetzt?
Ist das eine Spitze gegen mich?
Nur weil ich das vielleicht im letzten Jahr nicht ganz gemacht habe
und die vielleicht erst beim zweiten Frost reingeholt habe?
Jetzt übertreib halt mal.
Hier sind wir jetzt beim Herzstück meiner Automation angelangt
und zwar einem Hunter Magnetventil.
Das wird wiederum über ein Shelly 1 gesteuert.
Da der Brunnen aktuell leider noch nicht tief genug gebohrt ist,
liefert er nur 150 bis 170 Liter Wasser
und es dauert etwa zwei Stunden, bis er wieder vollgelaufen ist
und ich wieder Wasser entnehmen kann.
Sobald das Magnetventil öffnet, wird das Brunnenwasser
durch den Hauswasserautomat hochgepumpt
und in drei IBC-Containern, also insgesamt 3000 Litern, gespeichert.
In der Shelly-App habe ich hierfür...
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich, warum der das gemacht hat.
Das schaltet ein, pumpt das Wasser raus, dann schaltet es aus,
wartet zwei Stunden, bis es wieder nachgelaufen ist
und dann... Ah ja, okay, das macht tatsächlich Sinn.
...für eine Automation erstellt, die das Hunter Magnetventil...
Der Beregnungskreis.
3000 Litern gespeichert.
...für eine Automation erstellt, die das Hunter Magnetventil
für jeweils zehn Minuten öffnet.
Das Ganze alle drei Stunden, also insgesamt acht Zyklen pro Tag
und pro Zyklus kann ich 120 bis 150 Liter Wasser machen.
Ich kann das Wasser entnehmen, komme dann in drei Tagen
auf etwa 3000 Liter.
Darf man in seinem Garten eigentlich überhaupt einen Brunnen bohren?
Ich meine, man muss jetzt nicht pipsicher sein als der Papst.
Ich habe damit keine Schmerzen, wenn das Leute machen.
Ich frage mich nur, wir haben doch in Deutschland garantiert
alles geregelt in der Richtung.
Wahrscheinlich darf man das gar nicht.
Also wir haben auch einen Brunnen im Garten,
aber den hat mein Opa selbst gebaut vor...
Also Brunnen, Brunnen ist gut.
Da ist ein Rohr mit einer Pumpe dran.
Und das hat er selbst gebaut vor Ewigkeiten.
Mein Opa hat generell relativ viel selbst gebaut.
Ihr kennt ja noch den Fahrstuhl.
Pfeifert-Fahrstuhl.
Und da funktioniert heute noch der Brunnen.
Manchmal ist er ein bisschen zugeschlampt oder so,
dann funktioniert er nicht richtig.
Um ein versehentliches Überlaufen der Tanks zu verhindern,
befindet sich in einem der Tanks ein Schwimmerschalter,
Gute Idee.
Der bei maximaler Füllung die Verbindung zwischen
Shelly und Magnetventil kappt.
Solange der Brunnen nicht durchgängig Wasser liefert
oder es wieder mehr regnet,
war das für mich eine relativ einfache Variante,
um auch in längeren Hitzeperioden den Garten
mit genügend Wasser zu versorgen.
Das, was du gemacht hast, ist ja ganz cool.
Und von der Idee ganz interessant auch für mich,
weil ich ja in Zukunft von meinem unendlichen Grundwasserbrunnen
offenbar auf einen Zisternen-Lifestyle umstellen werde
oder müssen werde.
Und das erfordert ja ein bisschen Umdenken.
Und du scheinst ja auch deinen nicht ganz so tiefen Brunnen
zu nutzen, um quasi deinen Puffer vollzumachen.
Jetzt wäre natürlich ganz spannend zu wissen,
wie viel du so für einen Tag Bewässerung brauchst,
wenn du jetzt 3000 Liter da hast.
Aber das ist vielleicht auch nur,
weil ich das nicht so richtig einschätzen kann.
Und du trennst die Verbindung vom Shelly zum Ventil.
Das heißt, du brauchst nochmal irgendwie einen Haktor dazwischen,
wenn ich deiner Sache sage.
Wenn ich deine Aussage gerade richtig verstanden habe.
Also das ist deine Methode, um dich vor dem Überlaufen zu schützen.
Und ja gut, das ist vielleicht die solidere Trennung.
Also du könntest natürlich auch statt die Automation,
wann das läuft, in der Shelly-App zu planen,
das Ganze in irgendwas Dynamischerem machen.
Home Assistant zum Beispiel.
Home Assistant.
Und dann einfach die Automation an den Tagen aussetzen
oder dem Shelly den Impuls geben,
bis der letzte Tag voll ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es Geschmackssache,
was dir über ist.
Ganz ehrlich, eigentlich, wenn man nur das hat,
finde ich das super Sache, das über die Shelly-App zu machen.
Da brauchst du kein Home Assistant
oder irgendwie dir über andere Sachen Gedanken machen.
Einfach Shelly, Shelly-App, fertig, aus.
Wenn das das Einzige ist, was man hat,
finde ich, lohnt sich das gar nicht so sehr,
da noch was drum herum zu bauen.
Sobald man noch andere Sachen hat,
ja, dann ist so was wie Home Assistant sicherlich sinnvoll.
Habe ich auch am Start.
Weniger Aktoren und ein bisschen mehr Software
oder ein bisschen weniger,
ein bisschen weniger Software
und dafür ist hart vorbei,
weil es dann keine Verbindung mehr zum Ventil gibt.
So, der Green hat mir Alexa für seine Motormarkise geschickt.
Hallo Andreas, wir haben hier auf unserem Balkon diese Markise.
Die lässt sich mit so einem Garagentoröffner ausfahren.
Ist das nicht ein Markisentoröffner?
Ziemlich lang geht das, eine ganze Nummer.
Angeber.
Und auch wieder anhalten und auch wieder einfahren.
Ganz einfache Sache.
Ich kann folgendes sehen.
Das Problem an dem Ding ist,
dass es natürlich nur diese eine Fernbedienung gibt
und die liegt mal unterm Sofa.
Natürlich.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding,
wo wahrscheinlich der Hersteller genau guckt,
dass man das nicht einfach mit irgendwas anderem ansteuern kann.
Deswegen habe ich mir folgende Lösung überlegt.
Die Fernbedienung hier sendet auf 433 MHz
und ich habe ungefähr mit dieser Konstruktion,
das ist so ein Arduino-Bastelkit, 433 MHz.
Hat er die Antenne selbst gedreht?
Ist das eine genau auf die Frequenz abgestimmte Antenne,
die du da hingewickelt hast?
Also es gibt ja fertige 433 MHz Module.
Da muss man keine Antenne mehr selbst drehen.
Mit Strom habe ich noch dran gemacht.
Einfach das Signal als Audio abgehört.
Was?
PC mit Audacity mir angeschaut.
Wait a minute.
Wie die einzelnen Bits aussehen.
Ach so.
Okay.
Der hat quasi so eine Art Oszilloskop gemacht mit Audacity.
Aussehen.
Und das dann mit dem Arduino auf einen ESP8266
mit dieser Foxmo Library als Alexa-Switch eingerichtet.
Und tatsächlich hängt jetzt einfach hier mal ein ESP8266
mit diesem 433 MHz.
Der hat quasi das Signal mitgeschnitten
und sich angeguckt, was da übertragen wird
und hat das dann quasi nachgebaut.
433 MHz Sender und Antenne.
Einfach lustig im Raum.
Also der hat sich das Signal angeguckt
und hat dann eine Firmware programmiert für sein ESP,
der quasi exakt das gleiche sendet.
Ja, eigentlich eine gute Sache.
Das kann man vielleicht auch nochmal schön machen.
Und meine Markise funktioniert jetzt auch über Alexa.
Das kann man schön machen.
Bedeutet, es bleibt für immer so hängen.
Computer.
Vollkommen in Ordnung auch.
Computer, Markise an.
Alexa wäre den Part, den ich dabei nicht bräuchte.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich über das Smartphone steuern.
Aber gut.
Oder ich würde es automatisch ausfahren lassen
anhand des Sonnenstandes oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber wenn man Alexa eh bei sich hat und das gut findet,
why not?
Computer, Markise aus.
Genau.
Und das Ganze kann jetzt natürlich auch hier
mein Home Assistant abhängig von der Helligkeit und Tageszeit
gesteuert werden mit anderen Sensoren,
dass die Markise bei Regen auch vorher einfährt.
So ist es mir egal, wo die Fernbedienung gerade rumliegt.
Ich kann es ja immer per Stimme steuern.
Ich weiß nicht wieso, aber die Umwandlung der Impulse in Audiosignale,
die du reverse engineerst, um sie dann wieder selbst zurückzugeben,
macht irgendwie, dass ich mich unwohl fühle bei der ganzen Nummer.
Warum?
Ich meine, das Ergebnis ist cool.
Hä? Wieso?
Das ist das, was du quasi mit dem Oszilloskop auch machst,
wenn du halt direkt an die Schaltung irgendwie drankommst,
guckst, was da zu übertragen wird.
Oder mit irgendeinem Logic Analyzer oder sowas.
Nur, dass er halt, weil es Funk ist, mitgeschnitten hat
und sich dann in Audacity das ein...
Das ergibt schon irgendwo Sinn, auch wenn es extrem pfeifert ist.
Auf die Idee wäre ich nicht gekommen.
Das ist quasi ein 433-Megahertz-Netzwerksniffer, ja?
Das funktioniert offensichtlich.
Wobei das besser geht.
Es gibt ja solche, wie heißt das?
SDR-Sticks oder sowas?
Nicht Stocks, Sticks?
Sowas.
Es gibt ja so Sticks, 433 und 800 irgendwas Megahertz.
Da kann man sowas ganz gut...
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung, genau.
Da kann man sowas ganz gut mitschneiden.
Und dann muss man das nicht über Audio und so machen.
Aber, ja.
Ist so eine gute Idee.
Du hast dir das da so hingebaut, wie du das haben wolltest.
Hattest ein schönes Projekt dabei.
Vielleicht kannst du da tatsächlich sogar noch ein bisschen
auf der Home-Assistent-Ebene abfangen, dass du jetzt...
Ja, so einen Stick habe ich mir auch mal gekauft,
um hier zu analysieren, was dann überall so verschickt wird.
Und das ist mehr, als man denkt.
Das sind Wetterstationen, Temperatursensoren und sowas.
Kann man alles abfangen.
Abfangen ist das falsche Wort.
Man fängt ja nichts ab.
Mitschneiden.
Wieder reinfahren.
Unterschiedliche Befehle geben kannst.
Also gerade jetzt mit den neuen Sprachassistenten auf Home-Assistent-Ebene.
Aber...
Ich meine, ich habe ja seit einem Jahr oder so,
habe ich ja auch so eine China-Chinesen-Wetterstation im Hof.
Und die überträgt auch paar 433 MHz.
Konnte man damit alles abfangen.
Es ist schon gut, auf der Terrasse die Sonne genießen zu können im Urlaub.
Und im Zweifel per Sprache zu beenden, wenn es genug Sonne war.
Oder sie reinzufahren.
Wenn du das vergessen hast.
Und diese ganzen smarten Funktionen jetzt auch für ein etwas älteres Varema-Modell nachzurüsten, finde ich super.
Ich war ja hier in der komfortablen Situation, das mit Varema zusammen machen zu können.
Und auch für eine etwas neuere Markise.
Hier das Video.
Falls sich das jemand anschauen möchte.
Nice.
Markisensponsoring.
POG.
Richtig.
Joe hat ein smartes Wasserfass.
Pumpe einschalten.
Das Wasserfass sah jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht so smart aus.
Joe hat ein smartes Wasserfass.
Da läuft Wasser raus.
Pumpe einschalten.
Ah.
So eine ganz normale Wifi-Steckdorsim.
Was ist denn das für eine Konstruktion?
Was ist das?
Das sieht extremly feifert aus.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein Fensterkontakt.
Jetzt erkenne ich das.
Jetzt checke ich das.
Okay.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich schönere Möglichkeiten.
Aber die Idee ist gut.
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe es erkannt.
Guckt mal.
Das ist halt eine Flasche, die halt dadurch, dass das Wasser steigt, nach oben mit steigt.
Und das hier ist ein Fensterkontakt.
Hier ist der Magnet und hier ist der Fensterkontakt.
So und jetzt schließt der Fensterkontakt und dann kriegt er quasi die Nachricht.
Fass ist voll.
Also die Idee ist mega cool.
Aber ich fürchte nicht sonderlich langlebig.
Die Idee ist aber schon geil.
Jetzt geht es aus.
Ist das eine Mausefalle?
Nein.
Das ist ein Fenstersensor.
Man sieht es doch.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Ich glaube aber, dass das nicht länger als ein paar Wochen hält.
Gut.
Mit einem Fensterkontakt?
Ja, genau.
Hat er einen Fensterkontakt zusammengeschoben?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Ja, richtig.
Ausgebaut ist es auf einer Schiene mit einem Türsensor.
Das ist richtig Next Level Bastelstelz hier.
Okay.
Das ist ganz fantastisch.
Wir sehen hier eine Klemme.
Wir sehen hier irgendwie dieses gebogene.
Das ist mit Heißkleber hat er das hier dran gepappt an beiden Stellen.
Nee, das wird nicht lange halten.
Aber das ist so ein schöner Proof of Concept.
Das müsste man irgendwie anders bauen.
Also es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten, wie man das machen könnte.
Ja.
Also zwei Sachen, die mir sofort einfallen.
Das erste ist ein Ultraschallsensor.
Mit dem Ultraschallsensor außen kann man ganz gut erkennen, wie voll der Stand von der Tonne ist.
Man könnte auch einfach den Feuchtigkeitssensor nehmen und den hier oben an den Rand pappen.
Und sobald der Feuchtigkeitssensor Feuchtigkeit senst, wobei es da vielleicht Probleme mit Regen und sowas gibt.
Und ansonsten gibt es bestimmt noch weitere Varianten.
Ich glaube ein Ultraschallsensor dürfte ganz gut sein dafür.
Aber die Idee ist schon pock.
Das weiß ich nicht, Shrike, aber ein Ultraschallsensor funktioniert.
Ja, Stromverbrauch ist mega gering so.
Da braucht ihr gar keinen Strom, außer beim Schalten da oben.
Ist schon eine coole Sache.
Wir sehen einen Schlitten mit einem Fensterkontakt, der per Wäscheklammer auf eine Einwegpfandflasche geklebt wurde.
Das ist, sagen wir mal, zugängliche Technik.
Sehr kreativ.
Das war jetzt ein gut einminütiges Video und jede Einsendung bekommt, wie gesagt, einen 50 Euro Amazon Gutschein.
Wenn ihr auch irgendwas habt, was ihr mir zukommen lassen wollt.
Solche Sorten von Sensoren gibt es doch garantiert auch schon fix und fertig, oder?
Was in der Richtung?
Ob ihr einfach euer Leergut recycelt oder irgendeine komplexe Shortcut, Smart Home, was auch immer Automation gebaut habt.
Werft die gerne unter zeug.com.
Wir werden das auch gerne unter zeug.com zeigen, in das Formular.
Und vielleicht seid ihr in einer der nächsten Folgen auch dabei.
Vielleicht könnte man sogar was mit einem Schalter machen.
Vielleicht könnte man auch wirklich was mit einem Schalter machen.
Einen ganz normalen Schalter?
Ja, müssen wir mal überlegen.
Lichtschranke.
Irgendwas gibt bestimmt einige Varianten.
Den Stundenlohn mal finden.
Gucken wir mal.
Ach so, Sensor.
Ja.
Levelsensoren, Schwimmer.
Ja, Niveausschalter, Wasserpegelsensor, guck hier, sowas.
Gucken wir mal bei Amazon.
Ja, okay, die Sachen gibt es fix und fertig schon.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie es funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, hier, guck, rechts, da schaltet es dann ein.
Ja, eigentlich eine richtig coole Sache, ja.
Und den Kontakt wahrscheinlich 3,3 Volt oder so, dann kannst du es überall.
Ach Quatsch, du brauchst ja gar keinen, das ist ja kein Sensor in dem Sinn, das ist einfach ein Schalter.
Das ist einfach ein Schalter.
Das stimmt, das mit Akkubetrieb, wobei man so einen Schalter tatsächlich auch an einen modifizierten Fensterkontakt anschließen könnte.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ein bisschen langlebiger sein, als die Heißkleberkonstruktion, die Radar am Start hatte.
Mal ausrechnet, dann ist der für ein einminütiges Video in diesem Fall ganz gut.
Michael hat eine smarte Zugangssteuerung für Hasen gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die haben die dann so eine RFID-Karte.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wir schauen uns das mal an.
Ich möchte unsere smarte Zugangssteuerung für unsere Hasen vorstellen, mit der über HomeKit der Zugang zum Freilaufgehege den Hasen ermöglicht wird.
Dazu habe ich mir ursprünglich aus dem Fachhandel eine Rückstauklappe besorgt, welche allerdings vom Durchmesser nicht gepasst hatte,
sodass ich die Klappenlösung...
...davon demontiert habe und auf das vorhandene Rohr, was wir bereits als Verbindungselement eingebaut hatten, angebaut habe.
Die Ansteuerung des handelsüblichen Modellbahn-Servos, welches die Klappe...
...wenn jetzt der Hase dazwischen steckt...
...beentsprechend öffnet und schließt, erfolgt über eine HomeKit-IP-Servo-Kontrollsteuerung,
die es ermöglicht, bis zu zwei Servos unabhängig voneinander anzusteuern.
Eine lokale Bedienung der Klappe ist durch einen batteriebetriebenen HomeKit-IP-Wandtaster vor Ort möglich.
Er mit einem Tastendruck...
...wo die Klappe bewegt.
Gegenwärtig wird die...
Da oben ist der Hase, der traut der Sache noch nicht so ganz.
Kritischer Hase sozusagen.
...Zugangsteuerung mit einer Teilautomation betrieben.
Da ist er.
Der Verschluss erfolgt manuell über den Taster von dem oder derjenigen, die am Abend den Stall in Ordnung bringen.
Und am Morgen erfolgt zum Sonnenaufgang über eine Zeit...
Die Homematic-Steuerung sieht schon oldschool aus, ne?
...gesteuerte Routine automatisch.
Das Öffnen der Klappe...
Sehr spannend, da haben wir die Tiere aus dem Titel dieses Formats auch direkt abgefrühstückt, also abgehandelt.
Ich hoffe, deine Hasen finden nicht raus, wie sie den Schalter da oben drücken und dein ganzes Konzept irgendwie zum Zusammenbrechen bringen können.
Das scheint aber bisher ja nicht aufgetreten zu sein.
Ich find's auf jeden Fall ganz interessant.
Und ich weiß, dass die Frage, wie lässt man Tiere rein oder raus, ja euch schon länger beschäftigt.
Ich hab es in Hühner...
Also ich lass Chico ganz einfach rein, Ross.
Nämlich die Tür auf und zu mache.
Ich hab zwar eine Katzenklappe, aber ich mach trotzdem die Tür auf und zu.
Das kommt ja nicht so oft vor.
Stellen gesehen in Kaninchenstellen.
Und ich hatte die Frage auch neulich mit Katzenbesitzern.
Da gibt's ja irgendwie diese Katzenklappen mit RFID-Erkennung.
Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Chico geht an die Tür von innen, macht Mau, Mau, Mau.
Ich will raus, dann mach ich die Tür auf.
Ich guck ab und zu mal raus oder auf die Kamera.
Die deckt ja die Tür auch ab.
Wenn ich sehe, dass Chico vor der Tür sitzt, mach ich die Tür halt auf und dann kommt Chico wieder rein.
Welche Katze da gerade rein will?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Hasen gechippt werden.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich bin bei Haustieren im Moment noch etwas ungeleckt?
Unbeleckt?
Unbefleckt?
Apropos Hasen.
Hasen, schon gesehen, wer das heutige Video sponsert?
Ach du...
So, das kleine Problem ist, das heutige Video hat überhaupt keinen Sponsor.
Ich wollte nur diese fantastische Überleitung nicht verschwenden.
Nice.
Stattdessen möchte ich dich an dieser Stelle einfach auf meinen Newsletter hinweisen,
in den ich einmal im Monat schreibe, den Spiel und Zeug Insider, wo es so ein bisschen Einblicke hinter...
Pfeife der Self-Sellout.
Was ich sonst so mache, was mich gerade bewegt, was ich mir an Equipment kaufe und was so Gedanken für die Zukunft sind.
Das klingt tiefsinniger als es ist.
Ist ein bisschen Unfug, ist ein bisschen Therapie-Session für mich.
Wenn euch das interessiert, dann tragt euch gerne ein.
Ist kostenlos, ihr könnt jederzeit gehen, wenn es euch nicht mehr interessiert.
Schaut doch mal vorbei.
Jetzt zurück zu euren Automationen.
So, weiter geht's mit Sascha.
Der möchte uns...
...pumpenloses Rasenspringen näher bringen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt, als jemand, der vielleicht im letzten Jahr die Pumpe ein bisschen...
...für ein anderes Thema...
So ungefähr sah mal mein Hochdruckreiniger aus.
Der hatte wohl noch ein bisschen Restwasser drin und ist dann auch gefroren.
Und dann habe ich den angemacht, dann hat es erstmal gemacht...
...und ist komplett abgesoffen, das ganze Ding.
Also aus allen möglichen Löchern rausgesprudelt, wo es nicht raussprudeln soll.
Wie da?
Ja, Wüste.
Und normalerweise macht...
Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
...ein Schwimmerschalter, der...
Oh, what the...
So, weiter geht's mit Sascha.
Der möchte uns pumpenloses Rasenspringen näher bringen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt, als jemand, der vielleicht im letzten Jahr die Pumpe ein bisschen...
...für ein anderes Thema.
Wir haben das Problem, dass unser Rasen so aussieht.
Ja, gut.
Es ist ja auch sehr trocken gerade.
Also, jetzt gerade nicht, aber es war lange sehr trocken.
Jetzt wird es ja wieder ein bisschen mehr sommerlich.
Wie da?
Ja.
Wüste.
Und normalerweise macht man jetzt ja irgendwie...
Aber ist ja eigentlich auch nicht schlimm, wenn es trocken ist, dass der Rasen halt auch ausgetrocknet.
Ich meine, was...
Okay, so sieht es halt aus, wenn es warm ist.
...da entweder...
Also ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, meine persönliche Meinung,
ich finde, Rasen wässern uns ist komplett verschwendet.
Und einfach trocken lassen, wenn es trocken ist.
Und sobald es regnet, ist das Ding wieder instant grün.
Boden und sprengt.
Oder man bullert.
Du lässt jetzt aber nicht einfach deinen Whirlpool da ab, oder?
Das wäre ein bisschen, also, ein bisschen geschummelt, würde ich sagen.
Das ist ein Versenkregner.
Für die überordentliche Sache haben wir das Problem, dass hier unser Tim Wiese langfährt.
Quatsch, da brennt doch kein Rasen.
Warum soll...
Denn da entzündet sich nicht einfach random mal irgendwas.
Da kann man keine Schläuche hinlegen.
Und im ganzen Garten Sachen zu vergraben.
Ich habe auch keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Deswegen habe ich...
Ich habe mir eine Reihenschaltung gebastelt.
Das geht jetzt so, ein Gardena-Verlegeschlauch.
Einmal im Kreis um das Grundstück rum geht.
Ich bin dann so eins...
Ach, guck mal, da gibt es ja im Abstand von ein paar Metern da so Wasserspringer.
...eine kleine Beete angelegt habe.
Und die dann die Fark war, das Wasser freilässt.
Und dann sind die in eine Reihe geschaltet.
So, da hinten geht jetzt zum Beispiel der eine Springer.
Der läuft immer so 10 Minuten im Wechsel.
Also, zuerst lief jetzt der da vorne.
Jetzt läuft für 10 Minuten der.
Und dann müsste der gleich wechseln und ausgehen.
Dann dürfte der da drüben angehen.
Okay.
Der ist jetzt raus und der da hinten geht an.
Jetzt sprengt...
Coole Sache.
Ich finde ein bisschen Verschwendung irgendwie.
Der Rasen darf, wenn es trocken ist, ruhig trocken aussehen.
Der Kollege für 10 Minuten.
Aber gut, jeder wie er mag.
Der geht vorne mit an.
Eine coole Konstruktion ist es.
Ganz entspannt hier.
Guck mal, da hinten fährt noch der Mähroboter rum.
...fahren.
Ich habe mal kleine schicke Beete angelegt.
Ich habe kein Problem mit Versenkregnern.
Und ich muss das halbe Gebäude, den halben Boden nicht irgendwie aufschneiden.
Sondern das geht so.
Okay.
Mehrere Dinge.
Also das Erste.
Das Zusammenspiel von Tim Wiese und Rasensprengern dieser Art triggern ein Trauma aus meiner
Jugend, als wir in der Halbzeitpause im Weserstadion etwas vorführen sollten, das aber nicht mit
allen koordiniert war und mittendrin dann damals vor, ich glaube, weiß nicht, 32.000
Leuten oder so, die Sache ins Wasser fiel wegen der Rasensprenger.
Aber das ist heute nicht das Thema.
Also du hast das offenbar an ein Außenwasserhahn angeschlossen, nehme ich mal an.
Und dann mit den Eve-Aquas einfach der Reihe nach durchgeschaltet, sodass der Druck der
Leitung ausreicht, um den Sprenger zu betreiben.
Das ist natürlich ganz interessant.
Die Tatsache, dass du sagst, du hast das Aufbuddeln umgangen.
Gut, du hast das Verlegerohr ja auch am Rand liegen lassen.
Am Rand liegen und nicht eingebuddelt.
Ja.
Gut, du hast es umgangen.
Du hast es erfolgreich umgangen.
Es ist nicht dem Mii-Roboter im Weg und du musstest nichts aufbuddeln.
Gut.
Einverstanden.
Du hast gewonnen.
Michael hat eine Beschattungsautomation in OpenHub gebaut.
OpenHub.
Monka S.
Java.
Hallo zusammen.
Ich möchte euch gerne heute mal meine Beschattungsautomatisierung vorstellen.
Die ganze habe ich in OpenHub umgesetzt.
Und zwar geht es darum, dass unsere Rollos automatisch auf 50% geschlossen werden,
wenn die Sonne durch die Fenster scheint und die Temperatur höher ist außen als die
Raum-Sol-Temperatur.
Das Ganze prüfe ich über Azimuth und Elevation.
Über was?
Was?
Und zwar schaue ich, ob die Elevation über...
Ich habe keine Ahnung von...
...und somit die Sonne schon aufgegangen ist und über den Azimuth, ob in der jeweiligen
Himmelsrichtung die Sonne steht, sodass sie ins Fenster überhaupt hineinscheinen kann,
weil sonst ist die Beschattung ja gar nicht notwendig.
Das Ganze prüfe ich außen die Temperatur mit einer...
Der Sonnenstand.
Okay.
Ich habe auch eine Hysterese eingebaut, dass die Rollos nicht automatisch die ganze Zeit
fahren.
Ja.
Wenn die Sonnenposition außerhalb des Azimuthes gewandert ist, fahren dann auch die Rollos
automatisch wieder hoch.
Für die Balkontür gibt es dann nochmal einen Sonderfall.
Die Balkontür fährt auch auf 50% Beschattungsposition, wenn der Azimuth übereinstimmt.
Allerdings ist hier ja der Sonderfall, dass man auf dem Balkon auch mal natürlich laufen
will, wenn gerade die Beschattung drin ist.
Deshalb kann ich mal kurz demonstrieren.
Sobald der Griff gedreht wird, fährt automatisch das Rollo nach oben.
Und das Ganze funktioniert natürlich auch wieder, wenn man den Griff wieder zurück in
die geschlossene...
Wie bekommt er den Stand des Griffes mit?
...Position dreht, hat natürlich auch den charmanten Vorteil, dass man sich nicht aussperrt,
wenn man auf dem Balkon sitzt, da der Griff ja dann automatisch in der geöffneten Position
ist.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ganz spannend.
Also mit dem...
Wie bekommt er denn jetzt mit, dass der Griff gedreht ist?
War da irgendein Kontakt, oder?
... Sonnenstand und der Aussperrverriegelung.
Also die ganze Thematik mit den...
... Sonnenstand wirklich an der genauen Position des Hauses mit aufzunehmen, habe ich jetzt
neulich zum ersten Mal so richtig wahrgenommen, als der Eve Shutter Switch, der hat in der
App eine Funktion, dass man sein Handy an die Fensterfront hält und er durch den Winkel
und den Kompass und weiß ich nicht, schwarze Magie so ein bisschen, bestimmt in welche
Richtung das Fenster gerichtet ist.
Und dann eben abhängig von solchen Sachen auch die Automation fahren kann.
Und ich hatte auch schon mit Kai, der die Elektroplanung für unser neues Haus macht,
drüber gesprochen, dass wir vermutlich auch irgendwie sowas in der Art zum Beispiel für
die Beschattung im Wohnzimmer machen müssen, weil unser Fernseher dem Fenster zugewandt
ist.
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Wobei das hier kein Problem ist.
Da scheint keine Sonne rein ins Wohnzimmer.
Das heißt, wenn ich davor sitze, habe ich immer das Fenster im Rücken.
Also nicht zu Zeitpunkt, wo man Fernsehen guckt.
Und gerade wenn man dann natürlich einen Präsenzmelder im Wohnzimmer hat, kann man
sagen, okay, da ist jemand im Fernsehbereich und passt das je nach Sonnenstand und Wetterlage
und weiß ich nicht was an.
Aber finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr spannend, auch das Zusammenspielen mit der Schutzmechanik,
dass du auf dem Balkon nicht ausgesperrt wirst, ist natürlich dann auch sehr hilfreich.
So, Patrick hat einen Paketkasten mit Nuki Opener öffnen.
Video geschickt.
Hallo Andreas, und zwar wollte ich dir meinen Paketkasten zeigen von DHL damals.
Und viele kennen das ja auch, DHL hat ja irgendwann den Service eingestellt, man konnte es nicht
mehr mit dem Handy öffnen und wenn man die Chips verliert, mittlerweile kriegt man auch
keine neuen mehr.
Jetzt habe ich den Paketkasten...
Moment, DHL hat sowas mal angeboten, hat aber den Service eingestellt oder habe ich das
richtig verstanden?
Die Chips auch, DHL hat ja irgendwann den Service eingestellt, man konnte es nicht mehr
mit dem Handy öffnen und wenn man die Chips verliert...
Da sehen wir mal wieder.
Dass zu viel Cloud-Service oftmals halt keine gute Idee ist.
Stell dir mal vor, du kriegst deinen Briefkasten nicht mehr auf, weil irgendein Cloud-Service
eingestellt wurde.
Fast so geil wie letztens, du kannst das Licht an deinem Fahrrad nicht mehr einschalten,
weil kein Cloud-Service mehr...
Mittlerweile kriegt man auch keine neuen mehr.
Jetzt habe ich den Paketkasten smart umgebaut und zwar habe ich das mit Nuki gemacht.
Hier vorne ist ein Nuki K-Pad, wo die Zugangscode für DHL, Hermes und die ganzen Paketdienste,
wo jeder seinen eigenen Code für hat.
Hier habe ich noch...
Moment.
Und wie kann man den Paketdiensten den Code übermitteln?
Haben die da irgendwie so ein Formular oder wie?
Der Fahrer muss das ja auch wissen.
Moment, man kann jedem Paketdienst einen eigenen Code geben?
Gut, ich möchte aber nicht, dass die bei uns die Haustür aufmachen.
Wenn man dann den PIN eingibt...
Die Haustür...
Ach, bei ihm.
Dann leuchtet hier oben noch eine LED und der Paketkasten öffnet sich.
Das Ganze habe ich realisiert über einen normalen Türkontakt, der über 12 Volt läuft.
Hier auf der Gegenseite habe ich einfach ein Türschloss angebaut oder, ja, mit Schrauben halt.
Ein normales Türschloss, wo ich die Falle rausgenommen habe und nur der Kontakt für die andere Falle,
für das Gegenstück da ist.
So.
Da müsst ihr mal den Lockpicking-Lawyer dran lassen, wie lange das hält.
Dann habe ich hier oben, sitzt nämlich das ganze Stück.
Ja, mit einer Hand ein bisschen schwierig.
So.
Und hier habe ich dann einfach von der Nuki den K-Opener genommen.
Hab den K-Opener...
Ich hätte viel zu sehr Bedenken, dass das einfach irgendwann den Geist aufgibt und der Typ das Paket nicht reinbekommt.
Als...
Als Summer verbunden.
Und die Öffnung für den Summer, das Plus- und Minus-Kabel, was den Summer öffnet,
habe ich mit einer LED verbunden, die vorne dann hier leuchtet, wenn...
Sobald der Summer geöffnet wird.
Das Ganze habe ich dann hier an einen Stromkabel mit einem Netzteil für 12 Volt verbunden.
Und so kann man das Gerät auch...
So ein Netzteil ist mir letztens abgeraucht.
Hatte ich im Keller auch so an.
So ein schaltbares.
Also so, wo man verschiedene Spannungen wechseln kann.
Habe ich rein und raus gesteckt.
Und auf einmal hat man...
Puff.
Sicherung im Keller raus.
Licht aus.
Alles aus.
Hat den Geist aufgegeben.
Du scheinst eine sehr große Kanone auf diese Spatzen ausgepackt zu haben.
Also wie ein Paketbriefkasten mit Nuki-Opener und mit dem Keypad.
Ist mir bisher noch nicht untergekommen.
Auf jeden Fall ist auch da mein Plan, eine Paketbox zu installieren in Zukunft.
Weil ich doch das ein oder andere Paket bekomme.
Also bei uns ist es ganz einfach.
Amazon hat keine Ablegebereinbarung oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Und auch keine Hinweise.
Amazon schmeißt das einfach immer über das Hoftor, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Nicht, weil ich das mit denen so abgesprochen habe, sondern weil die keinen Bock haben, das wieder mitzunehmen.
Das liegt dann einfach hinterm Hoftor.
Hatte ich schon öfter.
Das liegt dann einfach so rum.
Egal ob es regnet oder so.
Das liegt dann einfach hinterm Hoftor.
Wenn ihr Erfahrungen an der Front habt, oder du, dann schreibt sie gerne unten rein.
So, Olaf hat was geschickt.
Auch hier geht es um Gartenbewässerung.
Aber bis jetzt ist noch nie, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob es noch nie war.
Ich kann mich zumindest nicht daran erinnern.
Also selten was kaputt gegangen.
Also wie gesagt, noch nie.
Wirst du jetzt nicht.
Schauen wir mal rein, was Olaf anders macht.
Alter, mein Ohr.
Das ist meine smarte Gartenbewässerung.
Die mittlerweile seit zwei Jahren ohne Probleme läuft.
Ja, bitte leiser reden und mehr Außengeräusche.
Den Sprühkopf habe ich in Fusion 360 konstruiert.
Oh, selbst 3D druckt.
Krasser Dude, Alter.
Das sieht auch richtig gut aus, oder?
Ist das selbst gedruckt?
Oder hast du eine Kamera, die die einzelnen Layer in diesem Fall verschluckt?
Ich glaube, das liegt am Material, in was er gedruckt hat.
Aber das ist wirklich gut geworden.
Muss man sagen.
Also hier oben sieht man es vielleicht ein bisschen.
Ja, doch, hier unten sieht man es.
Aber das ist gut geworden.
Weiß, danke schön für den Sub.
Das könnte bei uns auch passieren.
Die pfeffern das übers Tor drüber und fertig.
Ist das selbst gedruckt?
Oder hast du eine Kamera, die die einzelnen Layer in diesem Fall verschluckt?
Ich habe jetzt übrigens auch so eine Fitnessuhr.
Ich habe keine Apple Watch, ich habe eine Garmin-Uhr, weil die einfach akkutechnisch länger hält.
Und ich muss sagen, das ist tatsächlich echt motivierend, damit zu tracken.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch Muskelkater als Fuck.
Oder ist das die YouTube-Kompression?
Jetzt haben wir einen handelsüblichen Gardena-Anschluss.
In der Mitte steht der Sprühkopf auf einem...
Ja, da fehlt eigentlich noch Gardena auf USB.
...Alu-Stab, der in der Höhe, je nach Pflanzenart, war wie...
...wie bei jedem Bewässerungssystem kommt es darauf an, wie viel Druck noch am Ende da ist.
Das ist bei jeder Frage im Leben, oder?
Hier ist es so, dass ich von diesen Sprühköpfen sechs in eine Reihe schalten kann.
Mit einem Abstand von circa zweieinhalb bis drei Metern.
Äh, das funktioniert nicht in Fiat-Schempel-Garmin.
Der Sprühkopf selbst sprüht im Radius von ungefähr 1,50 Meter.
Und in einem Halbkreis.
Weil die Garmin-Uhr...
Also bei einer Uhr mit WLAN vielleicht, dass du halt auf den Service zugreifen könntest.
Das habe ich so über einen Verteiler realisiert.
Von hier aus gehen vier Stränge ab.
Olaf hat auch die Pläne mitgeschickt.
Die könnt ihr euch auch über den Link in der Videobeschreibung runterladen.
Für 2,50 Euro verkauft er die Bauanleitung.
Und dann könnt ihr euch logischerweise so viel davon drucken, wie ihr braucht.
Ja, naja.
Und Ersatzteile, wenn irgendwann mal was kaputt geht, kann man einfach neu wieder drucken.
Interessant, vielen Dank dafür.
Das 3D-Modell will ich mir mal angucken.
Okay, ne, hier sieht man schon die Layer.
Aber es ist gut geworden, was er da gebaut hat.
Sehr POG.
Und dieses 3D-gedruckte Zeug ist erstaunlich widerstandsfähig.
Endlich wieder 3D gedruckt.
Moin Moritz, auch am Start.
Neun Dreispurler, da POG.
Das ist extrem.
Nice, nice.
Aber das 3D-gedruckte Zeug hält länger, als man so denkt.
Ultimative...
Also ich würde sagen, die Ventile und so, die gehen wahrscheinlich eher kaputt.
Bevor, oder die Dichtungen gehen eher kaputt, bevor das 3D-gedruckte Zeug kaputt ist.
Das ist wirklich sehr stabil.
Ich hab ja auch paar 3D-gedruckte Sachen im Einsatz.
Das ist echt...passt, ne?
Ich hab zum Beispiel ein ganzes Regal hängen nur an 3D-gedruckten Sachen.
Von uns, kein Problem.
Werkzeug für Haustierbesitzer, den Futterautomat von David.
Für seine Katzen.
Das Original, wie es einmal gebaut war.
Eigentlich recht simpel.
Hier war einfach nur ein Uhrwerk drin, was man hier bis auf 48 Stunden drehen konnte.
Und dann sollte das ganze Teil aufgehen.
Problem war so ganz genau, war das nicht einzustellen.
Ich hab das manchmal, wenn man es auf 4 Stunden gestellt hat, ging es mal...
Ja, das sieht ja auch noch richtig oldschool analog aus.
War schon nach 3 auf, manchmal auch erst nach 6 Stunden auf.
Und ich wusste natürlich auch nicht wirklich, ob es aufgegangen ist, wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht...
Ja, das ganze machen wir doch einfach mal smart.
Und hier sieht man das gut auf der anderen Seite, schön im Vergleich.
Ist das ein Switch-Bot?
Mit Heißkleber draufgeklebt ein Switch-Bot?
Ein Switch-Bot...
Ja.
Wie heißt der Switch-Bot?
Button...
Ich glaub, da heißt es einfach nur Switch-Bot.
Das war nämlich der allererste Switch-Bot, dieser Schalter-Ding.
Eigentlich hat der Futterautomat zwei Fächer und hat auch zwei Einstellmöglichkeiten.
Da wir aber zwei Katzen haben, gehen wir...
Aber trotzdem zwei.
Sollen bei uns immer beide Fächer gleichzeitig aufgehen, deswegen hab ich das ganz einfach verbunden wie Deckel.
Der Vorteil ist, ich brauch auch nur eine Seite umbauen und das regelt sofort beides.
Ja, wie hab ich das gemacht?
Ihr seht schon, hier hab ich einen Switch-Bot-Bot verbaut, der quasi die Verriegelung übernimmt und das öffnet, wenn ich das möchte.
Zusätzlich hab ich hier einen Kontaktschalter.
Okay.
Der ist verbunden mit einem Acara-Türschalter.
Acara-Tür- und Fenstersensor.
Das hab ich deswegen nochmal zusätzlich gemacht, damit ich auch wirklich eine Nachricht bekomme, wenn es geöffnet worden ist.
Dass du sicher bist, dass es offen ist, ja.
Kann ja auch mal passieren, dass irgendwas streikt, der Switch-Bot nicht richtig funktioniert.
Dann kann ich das nochmal manuell nachauslösen, wenn es nicht geklappt haben sollte.
Ja, wie funktioniert das Ganze?
Recht simpel.
Futter rein, natürlich.
Klappe wird geschlossen.
Dann ist der automatisch verriegelt.
Eigentlich eine recht simple, coole Sache, was er da gebaut hat.
Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass das sonderlich viel Krafteinwirkung standhalten würde.
Gerade auf der Seite, wo das ja nur hiermit verbunden ist.
Also wenn die Katze es auf der Seite aufkriegen will und weiß, dass sie da eigentlich nur ordentlich genug dran ziehen muss, vielleicht wird sie das hinkriegen.
... gilt.
Und dann gehe ich zu unserem Tablet im Wohnzimmer.
Okay.
Gehe auf unsere Einstellungsseite und habe hier den Futterautomat.
Kann dann Uhrzeit einstellen, aktuell ist 16 Uhr eingestellt und gehe auf Programmieren.
Damit weiß mein Smart Home, um 16 Uhr soll ich die Katzen füttern.
So weit, so einfach.
Ja, da es bis 16 Uhr jetzt noch ein paar Stündchen sind, werde ich das Ganze jetzt einfach einmal manuell auslösen, um euch das zu zeigen.
Dauert ein paar Sekunden.
Zwecks der Bluetooth-Verbindung geht das nicht ganz so schnell, aber ich bekomme sofort eine Nachricht.
Also eine an sich recht simple Konstruktion.
Coole Sache, ja.
Katzen sind gefüttert, ich weiß Bescheid, wenn ich unterwegs bin, dass ich mir da keine Sorgen drum machen kann.
Okay.
Man könnte aber auch einfach ein bisschen Trockenfutter in der Wohnung verteilen.
Ich meine, Chico, also ich kann doch nicht sagen, wie es bei Chico ist.
Chico hat hier oben Trockenfutter, hat im Wohnzimmer Trockenfutter, hat unten im Flur Trockenfutter.
Und die läuft den ganzen Tag rum und futtert mal hier ein bisschen, mal da ein bisschen und sowieso.
Also da ist überhaupt nichts, wo ich irgendwie ein Fütterautomat bräuchte.
Die kriegt, also wenn die wirklich Hunger hat, ja.
Die kriegt natürlich, wenn sie unten dann vorbeikommt, mau mau mau, die kriegt morgens ein bisschen Futter, also nasses Futter.
Die kriegt mittags und abends auch noch ein bisschen nasses Futter, immer wenn sie will.
Also Chico macht das eigentlich so, genau wie Katzen in der freien Wildbahn das auch machen.
Die frisst mehrfach am Tag kleine Portionen.
Also ich bräuchte gar keinen Futterautomat für die.
Zumindest nicht, wenn ich nur einen Tag weg bin.
Natürlich, wenn du jetzt zwei Katzen hast und nur zwei Fächer, ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt eher für den Tagestrip als für den Urlaub.
Ja, bei mir liegt genug Futter für den ganzen Tag.
Das interessiert Chico nicht.
Chico geht hin, wenn sie Hunger hat, frisst ein bisschen was und geht wieder weg.
Die frisst nicht alles auf einmal.
Ein bisschen zu weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt bei der Ankündigung.
Aber ich nehme das mal so mit.
Ich habe auch keine Katzen.
Ich nehme das mal so mit.
Das ist die 0815-Aussage für jedes Meeting, wenn man was machen soll.
Und die nächsten Wochen kann man dann immer erzählen, ah, da bin ich dran.
Ich kann das also nicht so genau einschätzen.
Aber ich meine, es gibt auch Futterautomaten, die das von Haus aus portionieren, damit man das über mehrere Tage machen kann.
Ja, automatisch schließen kann das nicht.
Wenn es um Trockenfutter geht, weil hier könntest du ja auch Nassfutter reintun.
Also hier kannst du ja alles reintun.
Wenn ihr was für eure Haustiere gebaut habt, dann schmeißt es gerne bei zeug.ql.
Schmeißt es gerne bei zeug.ql.
Gerade wenn es auch vielleicht für mehrere Tage ist, dann können wir das in einer der nächsten Folgen aufrollen.
Oder wenn ihr irgendwas völlig anderes gebaut habt.
Wenn ihr ein Bett habt, das euch morgens rauskippt, wenn der Wecker klingelt.
Oder...
Oh, das wollte ich auch mal gucken, aber 31 Minuten ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Leute, ich muss aufs Klo.
Und danach muss ich was essen.
Ich habe mega Hunger.
Zu viel Sport gemacht.
Und Muskelkater habe ich auch noch.
Ich gehe jetzt schon auf.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich heute Nachmittag nochmal am Start.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Bisschen früher Schluss heute.
Bis denn. See you.